Three difficult stories tonight and
hopefully my plan is to get through all
three of them,
so we'll see how that goes.
So we're going to talk about the story
of Sodom and Gomorrah and then the story
of the,
the sacrifice of Isaac,
which an extremely complicated,
complicated story and so we'll try to
make some headway with that.
The story of Sodom and Gomorrah is
plenty complicated too.
Alright,
so what we established last week,
at least in part,
was this idea that the abrahamic
narratives are set up as punctuated
ipacs I suppose in Abraham's life and we
were hypothesizing that you know,
you set out a goal for yourself and your
life.
It's like a stage in your life.
You might say that and then when you run
that goal to its end,
when that stage comes to an end,
then you have to regroup and Orient
Yourself.
Once again.
And I was making the case that that's a
good time to make necessary sacrifices.
You know,
part of that's because as you move
through your life,
you have to shed that which is no longer
necessary and because otherwise it
accretes around you and holds you down
and you perish sooner than you should
and I think that's in large part because
if you don't dispense with your life as
you move through it,
then the stress of all that undone
business and all those unmade decisions
turns into a kind of chaos around you
and that chaos puts you in a state of
psychophysiological emergency
preparedness chronically and that just
ages you and so it's necessary in some
sense,
to stay light on your feet and also I
think to renew your commitment to your
aim upward.
And I believe that that's what the
sacrificial routines in the abrahamic
stories dramatize.
I said already that these things are
often first portrayed very dramatically
and concretely before they become
psychologist and we'll see because one
of the things that happens tonight as
well in these stories is that when God
makes his covenant with Abraham,
this is the next part of the story.
It's also when the idea of circa
circumcision is introduced into ancient
Hebrew culture.
Now there's every bit of evidence that
other cultures,
we're utilizing circumcision beforehand,
so it wasn't necessarily a novel
invention of the Abrahamic people,
but I see it's introduction as a step on
the road to this psychologist creation
of the idea of of sacrifice,
right?
First of all,
it's giving up something concrete and
then second,
it's signified by the sacrifice of a
part of the body instead of for the sake
of the whole.
It's something like that.
It's dramatizing the idea that you have
to give up a part of yourself for the
sake of the whole and eventually well by
modern times that becomes virtually
completely psycho psychological and it's
in its essence in that we all understand
perhaps not as well as we should,
but at least well enough to explain it,
that it's necessary to make sacrifices
to move ahead in life.
One of the themes that I'd like to
explore tonight in relationship,
especially to the sacrifice of Isaac,
is that,
you know,
once humanity had established the idea
that sacrifice was necessary to move
ahead,
which is really a discovery of
incalculable magnitude,
right?
The idea that the idea that you can give
up something in the present and that
will in some sense ensure a better
future is an unbelievable achievement.
It's equivalent to the discovery of the
future.
utility of work.
Like it's importance cannot be
overstated.
Okay,
so it took a long time for people to
figure this out.
Animals haven't figured it out at all.
Right?
We've figured it out and it's hard.
It's hard for people to make sacrifices
because of course the president has a
major grip on you as it should because
in some way you live in the present.
So anyways,
there's the twin problem of getting the
whole idea of sacrifice up and running
and then figuring out exactly what it
means,
but there's a problem that branches off
that tour a twofold problem.
So the hypothesis is that sacrifice is
necessary to ensure the,
that the future is safe and secure and
productive and positive and all of those
things.
Okay.
So then the question immediate two
questions immediately rise from that
right?
One is,
well,
what's the proper sacrifice?
Now we already talked about that a
little bit with regards to Cain and Abel
and one of the things we saw was that
keynes sacrifice,
whatever it was,
was wrong and ables was right.
No,
is seemed to be right.
Abraham seems to right.
There is something about a sacrifice
that can be correct.
There's something about a sacrifice that
can be incorrect.
The question is what would be the
maximally correct sacrifice?
So because that's an obvious question to
arise from the mere observation that
sacrifice is necessary.
Okay.
If you're going to sacrifice and it's
necessary,
well how is it that you would behave if
you were going to do it really well?
If you're going to do it perfectly.
Okay.
So that's question number one.
And then question number two might be,
well,
if the future can be better because of a
sacrifice and sacrifice is can vary in
quality than how much better could the
future be?
If your sacrifice was of the highest
quality,
right?
There's a limit issue there and the
limit is something like,
well,
how good could your life be if you
really got your act together and you
gave up all the things that were
impeding you in your movement forward.
If you did that forthrightly and with
integrity and with seriousness with with
dead seriousness,
and you tried to set your life right,
what is the upper limit with regards to
how your life might lay itself out?
And I would say,
well,
we don't know the answer to that,
but I think that the idea of something
like the city of God or the Kingdom of
God on Earth or the reestablishment of
paradise,
something like that is the answer of the
imagination to the question,
how good could the future be if
sacrifice was optimized?
And those are archetypical questions,
right?
An architectural question is a question
that everyone asks whether they know it
or not because sometimes you can act out
a question and the question is a
question that everyone asks and an
archetypal answer is the answer that
can't be made any better to that
question,
so I can give you an example of that.
The reason that Christ's passion is an
archetypal story is because it's a kind
of limit,
right?
It's the worst possible set of things
that can happen to the best possible
person,
so it's a story that constitutes a
limit.
It has nothing to do with the factual
reality of the story.
That's a completely independent issue.
I'm speaking about this psychologically
is that certain stories can exhaust
themselves in a perfect form and that
would be the architectural form.
So that's the territory that we're going
to wander around in a little bit today
and we'll use the stories as anchors
been thinking a lot about the Sodom and
Gomorrah story because it has a.
it's classically associated with a
biblical injunction against
homosexuality and that's often how it's
read.
I would say in particular by the more
fundamentalist end of the Christian
spectrum,
and I've thought about that a lot
because it's pretty damn clear that the
story of Sodom and Gomorrah has
something to do with sexual impropriety,
but I've really come to the conclusion
that it's very little to do with
homosexuality,
so we'll see how that interpretation
prevails as we walked through this
tonight.
Okay,
so we'll start with a bit of a recap
from last week.
So Abraham's had his.
He had his last adventure and he's 90
years old,
99 years old.
The Lord appeared to Abraham and said
unto him,
I am the Almighty God.
Walk before me and be thou perfect.
Well,
that's quite the command.
Now,
Alexander mcclaren,
who we talked about before,
it's a elaborated upon this slightly and
this is what he had to say.
This is not precisely walking with God,
the idea of walking before God.
It is rather that have an active life
spent in continual consciousness of
being naked and open before the eyes of
him to whom we have to give an account.
Okay?
So that's,
that's an idea that's in keeping with
the notion that what we're seeing in
Abrahamic story is the call to adventure
of the,
of man of the typical person,
right?
Because your life in some sense is an
adventure.
And I suppose the reason for that is
that you're confronted by things that
you cannot understand,
that you have not yet mastered.
There's a heavy price to be paid if you
fail to conduct yourself appropriately,
and there's a large reward to be gained
if you conduct yourself properly.
And so that pretty much defines an
adventure story and God calls to Abraham
and tells him to move out into the
world,
to leave what he's familiar with,
to go into the strange lands of famine
and tyranny and to find his place.
And that works out quite nicely for
Abraham.
And so what that also means is that
because Abraham is doing that
consciously,
at least according to this
interpretation,
that he's not naive in his,
in his determination to move forward.
You know,
I mean,
I've dealt with lots of people who have
anxiety disorders,
you know,
and one thing about people who have
anxiety disorders is they are not
mysterious to me.
I understand.
It's no problem for me to understand why
people have anxiety disorders or why
they're depressed or why they have
substance use problems.
The mystery to me is always white people
don't have all of those things at once
because everybody has a reason to be
anxious.
In fact,
we have the ultimate reason to be
anxious because we know that we're
vulnerable and we know that we're going
to die and how you can not be anxious
under those circumstances is a great
mystery.
It's a massive mystery and that same
thing applies with regards to depression
and then the same thing applies to some
degree with regards to drug and alcohol
abuse.
As I said last week,
there's plenty of reasons to drown your
consciousness and alcohol.
That's for sure.
We could refer to the aforementioned
anxiety and depression not least and so
and the and the sorts of drugs that
people are prone to take our chemicals
that take the effect of edge off the
tragedy of life,
so,
so back to back to the issue of of of
fear.
Being Abraham is self conscious.
That's what this commentary he says,
but the thing is as he moves forward,
despite that he self conscious and he
knows the danger,
but he moves forward despite that and
that's actually the appropriate response
in the face of actual non naive
understanding of what constitutes life.
Like if you're naive and you move
forward,
it's like,
well,
what the hell do you know?
You know there's no courage and naivety
because you don't know what there is to
stop you.
You don't know what dangers you might
apprehend,
but to be aware of what it is that your
problem is.
So to be alert existentially,
let's say,
or to be fully self conscious means that
you're perfectly aware of your
limitations and how you might be hurt
and then to make the decision to move
forward into the unknown and the land of
the stranger.
Anyways,
that's the.
I would say that's one of the secrets to
a good life and I can say that really
without fear of contradiction,
I would I would say because the clinical
literature on this as very,
very,
very clear what you do with people who
are afraid and to some degree depressed
but certainly anxious,
is you lay out what what they're anxious
about,
first of all in detail.
What is it that you're afraid of?
What might happen,
and then you decompose it into small
problems,
hypothetically,
manageable problems,
and then you have the person expose
themselves to the thing that they're
afraid of.
And what happens isn't that they get
less afraid.
That isn't what the clinical literature
indicates.
Exactly.
What happens instead is they get braver
and that's not the same thing,
right?
Because if you get less afraid,
it's like,
well,
the world isn't as dangerous as I
thought it was.
You know,
silly me.
If you get braver,
that's not what happens.
What happens is,
yeah,
the World Damn worlds just as dangerous
as I thought,
or maybe it's even more dangerous than I
thought,
but it turns out that there's something
in me that responds to taking that on as
a voluntary challenge and grows and
thrives as a consequence,
and there's no doubt about this.
Even the psychophysiological findings
are quite clear if you,
if you can.
If you impose a stressor on two groups
of people and on one group,
the stressor is imposed in voluntarily
and on the other group.
Destresser is picked up voluntarily.
The people who pick up the stress or
voluntary voluntarily use a whole
different cycle physiological system to
deal with it.
They use the system that's associated
with approach and challenge and not the
system that's associated with defensive
aggression and withdrawal and the system
that is associated with challenges,
much more associated with positive
emotion and much less associated with
negative emotion.
It's also much less hard on you because
the defensive posturing system,
the prey animal system man would not
thing kicks in.
It's all systems are go for you.
You know you're the gas is pushed down
to the are the pedals,
pushed down to the metal and the brakes
are on.
You're using future resources that you
could be storing for future time right
now in the present to ready yourself for
emergency.
So there's,
there's,
there's nothing simple or trivial at all
about the idea of being called to move
forthrightly forward into this strange
and the unknown and there's a real
adventure that's associated with that,
right?
So that's an exciting thing,
which is part of the reason why people
travel.
And then also to see yourself as the
sort of creature that can do that is
willing to do that on a habitual basis
is also the right kind of tonic for,
I hate this word for yourself.
Esteem,
you know,
because the self esteem has nothing to
do with feeling good about yourself.
As a,
as I already mentioned,
there isn't necessarily a reason why a
priority you should just feel good about
yourself.
But if you can view yourself acting in a
courageous and forthright manner and
encountering the world and trying to
improve your lot and,
and,
and taking risks,
you know,
in a non naive way,
well then you have something that you
can comfort yourself with at night when
you're wondering what the whole damn
point of view of your few tiles and
miserable life and so and that's
necessary because it's often the case
that you wake up at four in the morning
or at least sometimes the case that wake
up at four in the morning when things
haven't been going that well and wonder
just what the hell the point is of your
futile and miserable life.
You have to have something real to set
against that.
It can't be just rationalizations about
how you know you're a valuable person
among others.
Even though that's true,
that's not good enough.
You need something that's more
realistic.
To set a against that and observing
courage in yourself is definitely one of
the things that,
that,
that could help you sleep soundly at
night when,
when things are destabilized a little
bit around you.
So back to the Covenant,
God tells Abraham,
I will make my covenant between me and
the and will multiply the exceedingly
and Abraham fell on his face and God
talked with him,
saying,
as for me,
behold my covenant,
my contract is with thee,
and thou shalt be a father of many
nations.
Neither shall thy name anymore be called
Abraham name shall be called Abraham for
a father of many nations.
Have I made the and Haber means hi
father and Abraham,
father of a multitude,
and I'll make the exceedingly fruitful.
I will make nations of the and kings
shall come out of the and I will
establish my covenant between me and the
anti seed after the in their generations
for an everlasting covenant to be a God
unto Thee,
unto thy seed after Thee.
And I will give unto thee and thy seed
after the the land wherein thou art a
stranger,
all the land of Canaan for an
everlasting possession.
And I will be their God.
I love that line.
Really the line about the land where you
are a stranger,
you know,
and everything that happens in the
Bible.
Almost everything that happens in these
more archaic stories in particular is
laid out geographically.
The metaphor is geographic,
so you moved to a land that you haven't
yet occupied.
Maybe that's full of strangers and then
the land is what's granted to you,
but it's perfectly reasonable to think
about this from the perspective,
from a more abstract perspective that's
much more relevant to modern people with
are incredibly complex societies.
You know,
it's definitely the case that if you go
into the land of the stranger,
which is exactly what you do when you
try out any new endeavor,
right?
When you start a new job or when you
start a new educational enterprise and
when you start a new relationship,
it doesn't matter.
You're out there and it's unexplored
territory.
Like the physical geography is the same,
but we don't live in the in,
in,
in the spatial world only.
We live in the temporal spatial world
and what that means is that the same
place can be different at a different
time and mean it can be completely
different.
And so if you're in your house,
but you have a new person in your house
while your house is new for all intents
and purpose,
because the territory surrounding that
new person is the territory of of the
foreigner essentially,
and the same thing happens to you when
you start a new job and you'll find that
when you start a new job,
especially if you stretched yourself a
little bit beyond your zone of comfort,
that you very much feel like an imposter
right when you're first there.
And then the question is,
well,
how do you master that?
And the answer to that seems to be,
while it seems fairly straightforward,
if the place that you're in has degree
of possibility,
if it isn't inhabited by demons,
so to speak,
the best way to act is to lift your aim
upward and attempt to get your act
together and to tell the truth and to
live a meaningful life and to do
difficult things.
All of that,
and that is the best way of mastering a
new territory.
And in all probability,
the degree to which you're able to act
that out is precisely proportionate to
the degree to which you're going to
become a master in that territory.
And that sort of thing can happen a lot
faster than people think.
You know?
It's,
it's really quite remarkable how fast
you can move forward.
If you can establish yourself somewhere
and prove yourself useful,
assuming that you're around people to
whom proving yourself useful actually
matters like I know perfectly well,
that you can end up in an employment
situation where you're punished for your
virtues,
right?
In which case you should just get the
hell out of there.
And really,
really you get out of there and you go
find somewhere where if you work hard to
do what you're supposed to do,
you're actually going to be rewarded,
right?
Because that's not a workplace that's
hell.
And you should just leave there.
So and God said unto Abraham,
Thou shall keep my covenant,
therefore,
Thou and thy seed after the in their
generations,
this is my covenant,
which you shall keep between me and you
and thy seed after the every man child
among you shall be circumcised.
And it's a mystery.
They're like,
why that particular?
Right?
What's dramatic?
I mean,
it certainly,
it certainly effects of man where he's
most concerned to be affected.
There's something like that.
And so it's a,
it's a sacrifice that has a certain,
I wouldn't say a certain degree of
unforgettable it.
That would be the first thing and a
certain degree of pain and threat that
goes along with it.
So it's not nothing.
That's the thing.
Now you can argue and I think there is
an argument,
a case to be made about whether or not
in the modern world circumcision is a
reasonable,
uh,
is something reasonable to inflict on
infants.
I don't want to have that conversation
at all,
but I don't think that's relevant to
this particular issue because we're
talking about something different.
We're talking about humanities attempt
to reconcile themselves to the fact that
something has to be given up in order
for something else to happen and to try
to really work through that idea and to
make it into a psychological reality and
so far what we've seen in the biblical
stories is that when you make a
sacrifice,
it's not really something personal or
psychological,
right?
It's something external and dramatic.
You give up something that you own.
You don't give up something that you are
or that's part of you and it's.
It's actually more of a sacrifice to
give up something that's a part of you
or something that you are than to give
up something that you own.
I mean,
it's a subtle distinction because in
some sense,
the distinction between what you own and
what you are is subtle,
right?
I mean it's not overwhelmingly subtle
but.
But people identify with their
possessions and they need to because
otherwise they wouldn't care for them
and they need their possessions in order
to live.
So their possessions are in some sense
integral to them.
But this transformation here have an act
that was external and associated
essentially with possessions to
something that was actually at least
part of the body,
brings it much closer to it,
brings it much closer to the,
to the,
to the individual as a psychological
reality.
It's something like that and you shall
circumcise circumcised the flesh of your
for skin and it shall be a token of the
covenant between me and you.
It's also a permanent marker.
You know,
and I've read a fair bit about practices
like tattooing and body scarification,
you know,
which is,
those are very,
very common practices,
right?
They're human universals actually,
no matter where you go around the world
immediacy,
a couple of things.
First of all,
almost without exception,
people wear clothing and sometimes it's
relatively minimal clothing,
but it's an often,
it's more decorative than protective,
but it's almost inevitably clothing.
And the other thing that you see is that
people do scar and tattoo themselves and
they do that in some manner to catalyze
their identity,
right?
They're trying to transform themselves
from a generic person in some sense to a
person that's been designed by their own
hand.
It's something like that there.
It's a,
it's a marker of developing identity and
some of it seems to be catalyzed with
pain.
You know,
the modern people who Tattoo,
and I'm not saying that I'm in favor of
tattooing because actually I'm not but
that.
But that's my own particular bias and if
you have a tattoo that's fine with me.
I'm also not saying that there's
anything wrong with it,
but one of the things you do see what
the people who have a to tattoo do
report is a couple of things is that the
pain is actually necessary and that the
pain is actually something that seems to
establish something like a memory.
So while it's a memory,
because of the pain,
because he bloody well remember things
that hurt,
but it's also a memory because it's
actually etched on you,
right?
It's not something that you can just
abandon and forget.
And so a circumcision is exactly the
same thing.
It's like you don't forget it because
it's part of you and so it makes a good
token for a covenant and so that seems
to be the rationale here from,
from speaking from a psychological
perspective,
it's to indicate as well that the damn
thing that's happening is serious.
And I think also that was the case with
the earlier sacrifices of animals.
So it's like modern people don't do
this.
Like you don't know how serious you
would take a vow with you sacrifice to
go to in your back yard.
You know,
it's actually a very dramatic thing to
do.
You know,
you think about it as primitive and
perhaps it is archaic and,
and,
and no doubt it is,
but it's also to,
to take the life of something and to
spill its blood.
That's no joke.
That's something you remember,
especially if you haven't done it before
and we actually don't know what we would
need to do in order to take something
seriously,
you know,
because we all do things like make new
year's resolutions about how we're going
to be better people and we don't do it.
And the reason for that,
at least in part,
is because we don't know how to make the
sacrifice sufficiently bloody,
let's say,
so that we remember that it's necessary,
right?
We don't take it with seriousness.
We don't think I should quit smoking
because I'm gonna die.
And we don't think through what that
means.
Like cat coughing,
your lungs out for three months in a
hotel bed.
Well,
your entire family is like half repulsed
and horrified and sorrow stricken at the
fact that this has happened far too
early.
You know,
we won't make that real enough to make
it serious and serious.
And,
and without that seriousness,
we won't do it.
So there's something to be said for
rituals of seriousness,
and I think this is one of them,
and he that is eight days shall be
circumcised among you.
Every man child in your generations.
He that is born in the house or bought
with money of any stranger,
which is not if they seed.
This is from Charles John Ellicott,
who was bishop of Gloucester,
the fitness of circumcision.
To be a sign of entering into a covenant
and especially into one to which
children were to be admitted consisted
in.
It's being a representation of a new
birth by putting off the old man and the
dedication of the new man unto holiness.
It's like a baptism.
That's right.
That's.
That's what's.
That's what's echoed there and of course
a baptism is returned to the pre
cosmogony chaos because that's what the
water indicates and return to the source
of life and then the renewal that comes
along with it,
so it's the.
It's,
it's,
it's a sacrificial idea in some sense
that if there is to be a new you,
that the old you has to dissolve has to
return to the solution from which it
emerged initially and to reconstitute
itself.
And so there's an echo of that idea
here.
The flesh was cast away that the spirit
might grow strong and the change of name
and Abraham and Sarah was typical of
this change of condition.
They had been born again and so must
again be named and the women could it
need be admitted directly into the could
not indeed be admitted directly into the
covenant.
Yet they shared in its privileges by
virtue of their concert ingenuity to the
men who were sponsors for them and
that's sariah changes her name equally
with your husband or you could make a
case and and anthropological observers
have made this case to that women
undergo a sufficiently a set of
sufficiently radical psychophysiological
transformations merely as a consequence
of being part,
being feminine in nature,
such that the additional rituals of
transformation that might be necessary
for men aren't necessarily in one of
those might be menstruation because
that's a pretty dramatic transformation
and there has been some indication that
circumcision is like a male.
It's like the male equivalent of
menstruation.
Something like that because of the blood
that's involved and because of the
locale.
And then of course the same thing as the
case with women when they give birth.
Because that's a particularly dramatic
thing as I just witnessed because my
daughter just had a baby this week.
So
for that
recent investigation,
this is from the Cambridge Bible for
school and colleges,
which if you want to read it is only 58
volumes.
Reasoned investigation is not tended to
support the theory that circumcision has
any connection with primitive child
sacrifice,
nor again,
that it took its origin from hygienic
motives.
Apparently,
it record represents the dedication of
the manhood of the people to God in the
history of Israel.
It has survived as the symbol of the
people belonging to Jehovah through his
special election.
This corporeal sacrament remained to the
Israelite when every other type of
religion or race had been severed.
See,
the other thing that that I read about
in relationship to this idea of the
multigenerational covenant had something
to do because God told Abraham to
include all of the people of his
household into this covenant and and
that,
that really meant that he was
establishing it,
a territory of ethics around them,
like the arc,
except the psychological equivalent of
the arch.
Right?
So it was,
it was a spiritual or psychological or
ethical territory that everyone who is
of that household was required to occupy
or obliged or perhaps privileged to
occupy,
and there was also an injunction to
Abraham with regards to his children,
which was that as he had established a
covenant with God,
which we could say is something like his
decision to to aim as high as possible
and to live properly as a consequence.
It's more than that,
but it's something like that,
that he also was under a sub,
the supreme moral obligation to share
that with his,
with the other men in his family,
especially as children and so and so.
I think there's also a call here to
adopting a sacred,
the sacred responsibility in
relationship to children that has to do
with ensuring that they understand how
to take their place in the world.
And I think that that's definitely
something very much worth considering,
especially given the emphasis in the
Noah story and the story of Noah,
that Noah had his.
That his generations were perfect.
Right?
As I said before,
it wasn't merely that he had walked with
God.
He had perfected his own relationship
with the divine,
let's say,
with the transcendent and I want to make
that concrete,
which is a strange thing to do with the
transcendent.
I mean people ask me all the time about
what I believe and of course that's what
I'm trying to explain while I'm talking,
but,
and,
and many people of course are skeptical
about the idea of anything transcendent
and,
and say transcendent eternal.
But that can also be addressed from a
psychological perspective because I
would say,
well,
if you have an ideal of any sort,
how is that not transcendent?
It transcends you.
That's the first thing.
And it doesn't exist in reality.
It exists in a place of possibility.
And believe me,
man,
we treat places of possibility as if
they're real.
Because people will call on you.
You know about your possibility to your
potential.
They'll say to you,
you're not manifesting your full
potential.
And you might say,
well,
what do you mean by that?
Potential?
It doesn't exist.
It isn't here now.
You can't measure it or way it.
You can't get a grip on it.
And they'll say,
don't rationalize you know perfectly
well what I mean when I'm talking about
your potential and so we could.
Then you do and everyone does and
everyone knows exactly what that means,
and so that's a metaphysical reality
that will immediately accept as real and
also castigate ourselves for not
fulfilling and others too,
because you're just not happy when the
people around you,
especially if you love them,
don't fulfill their potential.
You really feel that something has gone
wrong and so there's a transcendent
reality and potential,
and then when you hypothesize an ideal
that you might pursue,
which you always do,
if you pursue anything right,
because to pursue something means you
don't already have it.
You're pursuing something that doesn't
exist.
You're probably not pursuing something
that's worse than what you already have
because why the hell would you pursue
it?
Right?
That's completely counterproductive.
So in the in the mere fact of your
pursuit,
you,
you pause it at transcendent reality
that you can,
that you can journey towards,
that's more valuable than the reality
that you have.
Now that's predicated in some sense on
something like an eternal verity or an
eternal truth.
It partakes in the ideal and so we have
an relationship with the transcendent
and you might say,
well,
that doesn't mean you have to personify
the transcendent,
say as Jehovah,
you know the,
the God,
the father,
but there's also some damn good reasons
for doing that because one of the things
that I've realized thinking through this
covenant idea and also the sacrifice
idea,
is that the idea that the future is a
judgmental father is a really,
really good idea.
You know,
because you think about what the future
is in part.
I mean the future is however,
the natural world is going to lay itself
out over the next endless amount of
time.
That isn't what I mean.
I think more about your future now.
Mostly your future is the future that
you're going to negotiate with other
people,
but they're going to be other people in
the future and some of those people are
going to be you in the future and family
members in the future.
And so what's happening right now is
that if you make the sacrifices
properly,
then you're actually pleasing that
future set of people and that future set
of people is definitely going to serve
as a judge.
It's exactly what it does.
That's precisely what it does.
And so you might say,
well,
it was the brilliant imagination of
mankind that hypothesize that the best
way to think about the social group,
including the family,
but he also including you as your future
self,
was to consider that you live in
relationship with a future father who's
a judge.
It's like,
yes,
that's exactly right.
Now is it right,
right?
Or is it psychologically?
Right?
Well,
it's at least psychologically,
right?
And one of the things I've learned about
the biblical stories is that to say that
they're psychologically right doesn't
exhaust the ways in which they're right,
but it at least gives rational,
modern people who are skeptical and
properly.
So a better way of getting a grip on
them.
So,
and the uncircumcised man child whose
flesh of his foreskin is not
circumcised.
That soul shall be cut off from his
people.
He has broken my covenant,
so it's a serious contractual array
relationship.
Now I was thinking about how to
understand this and I remember this old
story which I'm going to read to you
about a monkey.
So there's an old impossibly apocryphal
story about how to catch a monkey that
illustrates this set of ideas very well
first.
So it goes to the story.
You have to find a large narrow neck jar
just barely wide enough in diameter for
a monkey to put his hand inside.
And then you have to fill the jar up
with rocks so that it's too heavy for
the monkey to carry away.
And then you scatter some treats around
the jar that are attractive to monkeys
and close to the jar.
And then you put a few of those treats
inside the jar.
And so that's the first part of the
trick.
And then the second part of the trick is
the monkey comes along and gathers up
the treats and then puts his hand in the
jar and grabs the treats that are in
there.
But it's narrow necked.
And so once the monkey puts his hand in
there and grabs the goodies and he can't
get his hand out of the damn jar,
and so then you can just come along and
pick up the monkey and like too bad for
the monkey writes like he should have
let go of what he had so that something
terrible didn't happen to them.
But that isn't what the monkey will do
because he can't sacrifice the part for
the whole.
And there's something about the
circumcision story that's about that.
It's about sacrificing the part to save
the whole.
And I mean there's an echo of that in
the New Testament,
if I remember correctly.
I believe it's.
I believe this is correct.
Although it might not be where Christ
tells his disciples to pluck out there.
I,
if it offends them,
seems like a very dramatic,
you know,
piece of advice.
But it's partaking of the same idea,
which is that now if there's something
holding you back,
we'll see this when we get to the story
of law to if there's something holding
you back,
even if it's dear to you,
you have to let it go.
You seriously have to let it go because
there isn't anything more important than
progressing forward and and cheap
sympathy,
cheap empathy,
cheap nostalgia.
None of that
is sufficient.
None of that will work because the
consequences of not putting things
together immediately are dire and
there's no time to wait.
And God said unto Abraham,
as for my wife,
thou shalt not call her name's Sarah,
but Sarah shall be her name.
My princess.
That was Sarah.
Sarah is mother of nations,
and I will bless her and give the a son
also have her.
Yay.
I will bless her.
She will be a mother of nations.
Kings of people shall be of her.
Then Abraham fell on his face and
laughed and said in his heart,
show a child,
be born unto him.
That is 100 years old.
He's got a lot of doll.
I would say.
I mean,
here's God talking to him.
Many laughs,
you know,
but that's okay.
That's he's a courageous guy and that's
what people are like and and she'll
Sarah,
that is 90 years old bear and Abraham
said unto God,
Oh,
that Ishmael might live before the.
And God said,
Sarah,
thy wife shall bear the son indeed,
and thou shalt call his name Isaac,
and I will establish my covenant with
him for an everlasting covenant and with
his seed after him.
And as for Ishmael,
I've heard the behold I have blessed him
and will make him fruitful and multiply
him exceedingly 12 princes shall he be
get and I will make him a great nation.
Now,
what does this mean?
This is.
This is a miraculous story in some
sense,
right?
Because.
Well,
Sarah,
it's what Isaac want or what Abraham
wants most is to have a song,
but it looks like it's pretty much
impossible and they,
I think what the story is attempting to
indicate is something like
God only knows what will happen to you
if you put your house in order.
Certainly things that you do not
currently,
regardless possible will happen.
And the more you put your house in
order,
the more things that you regard as
impossible will happen.
And it might be the case that if you put
your host together sufficiently,
things that were of miraculous
impossibility would happen to you well,
and there's no way of knowing until you
try it,
but there's no way of being sure that
it's not the case unless you do.
And my experience has been
that I don't mean just personally.
I mean that
the world is a remarkable and mysterious
place and the relationship between the
nature and structure of the world and
your actions is indeterminant.
They may be more tightly related than
you think.
And I don't know how to square that with
the fact that while you're obviously in
a mortal body and constrained by all
sorts of serious
constraints,
none of that,
none of that's true.
It can be trivially overcome.
And I don't really understand how there
can be that seriousness of mortal
constraint and the infinite potential
that also seems to characterize human
beings all at the same time.
But then I don't really understand
anything about the nature of reality.
So that's just one more mystery to add
to the pile.
So,
but my covenant,
I will establish this Isaac,
which share a Sarah shall bear under the
at the set time next year,
and he left off talking with them and
God went up from Abraham and Abraham
took Ishmael,
his son and all that were born in his
house and all that were bought with his
money,
every male among the men of Abraham's
house and circumcised the flesh of their
forest skin in the selfsame day,
as God had said unto him,
that must have been an interesting
conversation.
That's been really.
This is what God told you to do.
A.
It's like,
okay.
And Abraham was 90 years old and nine
when he was circumcised,
circumcised in the flesh of his for
skin.
And Ishmael was 13 years old when he was
circumcised in the selfsame day was
Abraham circumcised and his son and all
the men of his house,
born in the house and bought with money
of the stranger were circumcised with
him.
Alright?
So that's the renewal of the covenant.
That's the next part of the story.
That's the circumstance.
That's the circumcision story,
and as I said,
it seems to indicate to me something
about seriousness of intent,
something about the responsibility that
Abraham determines to take for everyone
that's part of his household,
these psychological,
increasing psychological transformation
of the idea of sacrifice,
the necessity of doing something
memorable,
and the the,
what would you call it,
the utility of rekindling the aims of
your highest values when you come to the
end of an air park in your life,
when you have to take stock again,
right?
You take stock of yourself.
That's really what that phrase means to
take stock as to take stock of yourself
and to decide,
okay,
well what should move forward in time
with me and what should be let go as if
it's dead wood and the more dead wood
that you let go of and burn off when you
have the opportunity.
The last it accretes around you here.
Here's something interesting about
forest fires.
You know,
people have been trying to prevent
forest fires for a long time,
especially that am bear smokey,
right?
He's trying to prevent forest fires and
so because forest fires burn up the
forest and that can't be good,
but here's what happens if you don't let
forest fires burn,
is that while forests collect a lot of
dry branches,
right,
because tree branches die and would
falls on the forest floor and collects,
and so the amount of flammable material
keeps increasing with time and that's
not so bad if it's wet,
but if the amount of flammable material
is increasing and it gets really dry and
then it burns,
then you have a real problem.
The forest fire can burn so hot that it
burns the topsoil right off,
in which case you don't have a forest at
all anymore.
You just have a desert and low.
Lots of trees are evolved to withstand
forest,
have a certain intensity and some won't
even release their seeds unless there's
been a fire,
and so a little bit of fire at the right
time can stop everything from burning to
the ground,
and that's also a really useful insight,
metaphorical insight into the nature of
sacrifice,
right?
It's also a lot easier to let go of
something when you're deciding to let go
of it because you've decided yourself
that you're done with that.
It's a weak part of you.
It needs to disappear.
You do that yourself.
It's much better and much easier than it
is if it's taken away from you forcibly,
in which case you're very much likely to
fight it.
These other.
There's another interesting thing here,
a motif that runs through the entire
Bible.
It's a very,
very powerful motif and it's partly
associated with this idea of walking
with or walking before God and in the
New Testament,
Christ says something like,
my fathers will be done and he means
that that will should be done through
him,
and so I can't.
I won't be able to state this exactly
right,
but it's something like this.
You know,
a lot of what people regard as their own
personalities and and are proud of about
their own personalities,
aren't their own personalities at all.
They're useless.
Idiosyncrasies that defer them,
differentiate them trivially from other
people,
but they have no value in and of
themselves.
They're more like quirks.
I remember once I was trying to teach a
particularly stubborn student about how
to write and she had written a number of
essays in university and got universally
walloped for them and the reason for
that was she couldn't write really at
all.
She was really,
really bad at writing and so I was
sitting down with her trying to explain
to her what she was doing wrong and she
was being very annoying about it,
very recalcitrant,
very,
very unwilling to listen.
That was a pearls before swine thing,
you know,
and at one point she said,
I can write perfectly well,
this university professors just don't
like my style and I could feel my hands
creep towards her neck.
Yeah.
Well that'd be funny if it wasn't true,
but it was also true,
you know,
and I thought,
what the Hell is with you?
You can't even write and you think you
have a style and normally do you think.
Yeah,
no,
not knowing how to write is not a style.
That's the other point.
Right.
And so,
you know,
she,
she instead of humbling herself,
which was necessary and okay.
Right.
Because she was a new university
students like,
of course you don't know how to write.
When were you going to learn in school?
I think so.
So she had this,
you know,
this,
this style issue in it.
It just,
it just didn't go anywhere at all.
And so now let's see.
I lost my train of thought and telling
you,
telling you all those jokes,
don't we ask in terms of above letting
things burn off.
Yeah.
Well,
so she was proud of her insufficiency
outs.
Arrogance,
right?
That's not humility.
It's self deception and arrogance to be
proud of your insufficiency.
That's a very foolish thing.
And that means to cling to the parts of
you that are dead.
Okay.
Now there's this idea that runs through
the Bible,
I think as a whole that.
Okay,
I'll tell you another little side story
here.
I was reading about socrates today and I
was reading about socrates trial,
you know,
he was tried by the Athenians for
corrupting,
for failing to worship the gods and
corrupting the youth of Athens by like
teaching them stuff and asking them
questions,
you know,
which is great way to corrupt people.
And so he knew the trial was coming and
Athens wasn't a very big place and only
had about 25,000
people.
Everybody knew everybody.
Everybody knew who the powerful guys
were in everybody,
including socrates,
knew that the trial was a warning to
like,
get out of town.
Right?
So we're going to put you on trial in
six months.
And the potential penalty is death.
Got that.
It's like,
so.
So socrates had a chat with his
compatriots and they were contemplating
fair means and fall to set up a defense
for him so that he could or to leave so
that he could not be tried and put to
death.
And uh,
he decided that he wasn't going to do
that.
And he also decided that he wasn't going
to even think about his defense.
And he said,
why?
And this is quite an interesting thing.
He said,
why?
He told one of his friends that he had
this voice in his head,
a Daemon is spirit,
something like that,
that he always listened to in that that
was one of the reasons he was different
from other people because he always
listened to this thing.
It didn't tell him what to do,
but it told him what not to do.
It always told them what not to do and
if it told him not to do something,
that he didn't do it.
If he was speaking and the little voice
came up and said no.
Then he shut up and he tried to say
something else.
And he was very emphatic about this.
And he said that when he tried to plan
to evade the trial or even to mount his
own defense,
the voice came up and said,
no,
don't bother with it.
And he thought,
well,
what the hell do you mean by that?
Like there's a trial coming and I'm
going to be put to death.
And while he eventually concluded that
he was an old guy,
you know,
the next 10 years he was in his
seventies,
perhaps the next 10 years weren't going
to be that great forum.
He got a chance,
maybe the gods were giving them a chance
just to bow out,
you know,
to put us in fares,
in order to say goodbye to everyone to
avoid that last descent into
catastrophe,
which might've been particularly painful
for a philosopher and to and to walk off
the world on his own terms,
something like that.
The point I'm making with that is that
socrates attended to this internal voice
that at least told them what not to do
and then he didn't do it.
And of course socrates was a very
remarkable man and we still hear about
them today and we know that he existed
and all of those things.
And so back to the back to the walking
with God idea.
You know,
as you elevate your aim,
you create a judge at the same time,
right?
Because the new ideal,
which is an ideal you,
even if it's just an ideal position that
you might occupy.
Even if it's still conceptualized in
that concrete way,
that becomes a judge because it's above
you,
right,
and then you're.
You're terrified of it.
Maybe that's why you might be afraid
when you go start a new job,
right?
Because this thing is above you and
you're terrified of it and the judges
you,
and that's useful because the judge that
you're creating by formulating the ideal
tells you what's useless about yourself
and then you can dispense with it and
you wanted to keep doing that,
and then every time you make a judge
that's more elevated,
then there's more useless you that has
to be dispensed with,
and then if you create an ultimate
judge,
which is what the architectural
imagination of humankind has done,
say with the figure of Christ,
because if Christ is nothing else,
he is at least the archetypical perfect
man and therefore the judge.
You have a judge that says,
get rid of everything about yourself
that isn't perfect.
Of course,
that's also what Abraham.
That's also what God tells Abraham,
right?
He says,
to be perfect,
to pick on ideal,
that's high enough and you can do this.
The thing that's interesting about this,
I think as you can do it more or less on
your own terms,
you have to have some collaboration from
other people,
but you don't have to pick an external
ideal.
You can pick an ideal that fulfills the
role of ideal for you.
You can say,
okay,
well if things could be set up for me
the way I need them to be and if I could
be who I needed to be,
what would that look like?
And you can figure that out for yourself
and then instantly you have a judge.
And I also think that's part of the
reason people don't do it right?
Why don't.
Why don't people look up and move ahead
and answer is,
well,
you know,
you start formulating an ideal.
You formulate a judge.
It's pretty easy to feel intimidated in
the face of your own ideal.
That's what happens to cane versus able,
for example.
Then it's really easy to destroy the
ideal instead of to try to pursue it
because then you get rid of the judge,
but it's way better lower the damn judge
if it's too much.
Like if you're current ambition is
crushing you,
you know,
then maybe you're playing the tyrant to
yourself and you should tap down your
ambitions,
not get rid of them by any stretch of
imagination,
but at least put the more reasonably
within your grasp.
You don't have to leap from point one to
point 50 in one leap,
right?
You can do it incrementally,
but I really liked this idea.
I think it's a profound idea that the
process of recapitulating yourself
continually is also the process of it's
a phoenix like process,
right?
You're shedding all those elements of
you that are no longer worthy of the
pursuits that you're,
that you're valuing,
and then I would say the idea here is
that as you do that,
you shape yourself evermore
precisely into something that can
withstand the tragedy of life and that
can act as a,
as a beacon to the world.
That's the right way of thinking about
it,
maybe first to your friends and then to
your family.
It's like it's a hell of a finance
ambition and there's no reason that it
can't happen.
You know,
every one of you knows people who are
really bloody useful in a crisis and
people that you admire,
right?
Those are all you can think of.
All those people,
as you admire that you admire us.
Partial incarnations of the archetypal
Messiah.
That's exactly right,
and the more that that manifests itself
in any given person,
then the more generally useful and
admirable that person is in a multitude
of situations and we don't know the
limit to that,
but people can be unbelievably good for
things.
You know?
It's really something to behold.
So that's what God tells Abraham.
Okay,
so the next story is about Abraham and
these angels.
Angels show up on his doorstep,
and this is part of the story of Sodom
and Gomorrah,
but I don't think,
as I said,
this story's generally read as if it's
about homosexuality,
but I don't think it is here.
I think it's about two things primarily.
One is
how do you treat the strange?
So the strangest,
strange things in strange ideas and
strange people and strangers,
right?
It's all about.
It's that which is not you.
It's like the strange lands that God
asked Abraham to move out into how do
you interact with the strange
and here,
here's one part possible rule because
you could say to yourself,
well,
what do I want to make friends with
more?
Where do I want to be more comfortable?
Do I want to be more comfortable with
that which I already know,
and so that would be the circumscribed
territory that you've already mastered,
or do I want to be comfortable with all
those things I don't know,
and then the right answer is that you
should want to be comfortable with all
those things that you don't know because
there is a bloody lot of things that you
don't know and if you can be a sojourner
among what you don't know,
well then you're so protected because,
well,
you're going to go lots of places where
you don't know and you're going to be
able to manage it.
So you want to be.
You want to be that person that can act
where they don't know and so well.
So what happens with with Abraham?
Well,
he's at home and these angels show up.
Now
we don't know whether they're angels,
men,
precisely because while as this part of
the story reads,
as the Lord appeared to him in the
plains of camera and he sat in the tent
door in the heat of the day,
so he's another visionary state by the,
by all appearances,
and he lifted up his eyes and looked and
lo three men stood by him.
There's real ambivalence in the story
about the man or the three men are the
three angels are there to angels and
God.
It's all mixed up in this story so we
won't clarify that.
We'll leave it ambiguous and I think the
ambiguity is important because you don't
know who the stranger is when you
encounter and it depends on whether
you're thinking about it in the
normative manner or if you're thinking
about it in the transcendent matter.
Because with each person that you meet
while they're just a person,
that's one way of thinking about it and
then they're the person that you know or
they're the person as they choose to
reveal themselves to you and people keep
themselves shielded.
But then there also something of great
metaphysical potential,
right?
And you might say,
well do you believe that?
And I would say,
well yes,
you believe it because you expect a lot
from people generally speaking and are
not happy if they betray you.
But more importantly,
our entire culture is predicated on the
idea that each person has an indefinite
intrinsic worth.
And I'm not talking about self esteem.
I'm talking about something like the
what,
what would you say it?
The implicit presupposition in our legal
structure that no matter who you are,
even if you're a murderer,
even if you're a condemned murderer,
that there's something about you that's
of transcendent value that has to be
respected by the law,
by the law and by other people.
Right?
And so that's,
that's a remark.
And you might say,
well,
you know,
do I believe that the answer that is
well yak it out because you follow the
law and it's not an easy thing to pull
out of the law.
It's kind of the idea that you have
intrinsic natural rights and you don't
pull that out of our law man without
having the whole thing fall down and I
think the whole idea that you have
intrinsic natural rights is predicated
on something like the biblical
hypothesis that human beings have,
a logos nature and that we are involved
in this speaking forth of being and as
beings who are who are involved in this
speaking forth of being.
There's something about us that has to
be respected by,
by ourselves,
in relationship to ourselves,
in relationship to other people,
but even more strangely by ourselves in
relationship to even to criminals,
even to vicious criminals.
You can't remove that transcendent
element and that's that to me,
that's also a mirror,
a miracle of conceptualization because
who the hell is going to think that up?
Right?
Even the most vicious of murderers has a
touch of the transcendent that needs to
be respected.
Of all the ideas that are unlikely,
that's got a top the list,
and of course without that you.
You have a very barbaric legal system,
right?
Because no one is protected as soon as
you make a mistake,
then you're in the.
Then you have no rights whatsoever,
and that isn't what happens in the West,
which is an absolutely amazing thing.
So anyways,
Abraham is a master of the stranger.
That's one way of thinking about it.
He knows what to do when strangers come
along and he opens his.
He opens himself up to them and I would
say he does that.
We know he's not a naive guy,
Abraham,
right?
He's no weakling.
A couple of stories ago,
he took a big army and went and harassed
a bunch of kings and took his nephew
back.
He's,
he's a tough guy.
And so if stranger show up and he
welcomes them,
it's not because he couldn't do
otherwise.
He could certainly do otherwise.
And it's not because he isn't aware of
what people can be like.
He's perfectly aware of what people can
be like,
but he determines to take a particular
attitude towards them and that is to
welcome them.
And so,
and why would you do that?
And I think the answer to that is you
hold out your hand in trust to someone
and you evoke the best from them if
that's there to be given.
So it's an act of courage.
It's like it's.
It isn't me meeting you.
Exactly,
not exactly.
It's more like the transcendent part of
me making a gesture that allows the
transcendent part of you to step
forward.
And that happens all the time.
It happens all the time in normative
discourse.
You know this perfectly well because
sometimes you can have a real casual
conversation with someone that just goes
nowhere,
right?
It's just shallow as can be or now.
And then you can actually make contact
with someone.
Right?
And you're both,
I would say enlightened down ennobled by
the conversation and that's a deal.
We would call that a deep conversation
for for some reason,
because we made a deep connection.
Whatever that means,
it means well,
it certainly means that it's not
shallow.
We were not sure about what these
metaphor means,
but it means that it reaches deep inside
of you.
It's something like that.
You make direct person to person contact
and those sorts of conversations are,
I'm replenishing that that's the right
way to think about it.
They genuinely are and I think that's
because they provide you with that bread
that's not material bread and that's the
information that you need to to thrive
and to put yourself together and so it
does matter how you meet someone and it
doesn't matter how you treat them when
you first meet them and it's amazing.
I've learned to do this at least in
part,
partly because I'm a clinical
psychologist.
I've learned how to talk to people very
rapidly and I have the most amazing
adventures with people in cabs and when
I travel because all talked to them
directly right away and they'll tell me
the wildest stories and show me the
craziest things because I'm actually
interested in what they have to say and
I'm not afraid.
Well,
I'm somewhat afraid,
but I'm not.
I'm not sufficiently afraid to have that
stopped me and I'm acting on the
presupposition that the person has
something of great interest to reveal
and that's a very useful thing to know
too.
Because one of the things that's really
cool about people that know you really
learn this as a clinical psychologist is
that if you can get people talking,
they're so damn interesting,
you can hardly stand it.
You know,
because they have these idiosyncratic
experiences that are only there is right
there only there's personally no one
else could tell the story,
and that's the kind of stories that you
want to hear.
And when they tell you those stories,
you learn something you didn't know.
And so what that means is that you can
treat the landscape of strangers as an
endless vista of places to learn things
you didn't know.
And if you know enough so that you're
satisfied with your life and everything
has ceased to be a tragedy around you.
Well then you can be comfortable in your
circumscribed domain of,
of totalitarian knowledge,
let's say.
But if you're,
if your life is insufficient and you're
suffering more than you want to and
everything isn't what it should be,
then you need to look where you haven't
looked for what you don't have,
and then you can look outside beyond
you.
And then you can make friends with what
you don't understand,
and that's a huge part of what this
story's about because what happens is
that Abraham welcomes the men,
God angels and treats them very well and
reaps a tremendous benefit as a
consequence.
And then,
well then the story reverses and we end
up in Sodom and Gomorrah were the same
angels sojourn and they're treated
terribly and all hell breaks loose.
And so that's what the story's about.
It's fundamental.
Now there's A.
There's a sexual impropriety thing going
on that I'm also going to delve into,
but I don't think that's the critical
issue in the story.
The critical issue in this story is how
do you act in the face of the stranger?
You know there's a statement in the New
Testament,
Christ says something like,
when you,
when you do something to the least of
people,
you do it to me him.
Right?
And that's a very difficult statement to
understand too,
but it's something like it's something
reminiscent of the requirement to keep
the idea of the transcendent reality of
the person in mind.
At the same time,
you keep their proximal reality in mind
to have to have your mind in two places
at the same time when you're talking to
people,
you know,
I learned from a friend of mine in
Montreal who's very socially
sophisticated in some ways.
Whenever,
when whenever he went into a store,
I always like going shopping with him
and whenever he went into a store and he
talked and he had an interaction with a
clerk,
the first thing he would do is have an
interaction with the clerk.
You know,
he,
he wouldn't have any interaction with
the role of the clerk.
He'd like look at the person,
sort of take stock of the fact that they
were there and then ask them something
genuine about their job or their store,
how they were doing,
like go into a conversation away and
he didn't get personal about it because
that can be intrusive,
right?
You have to be very sophisticated to do
this,
but he did indicate to the person that
he was there,
at least in part for the good that could
be done between them.
It's something like that.
And then the person would be
ridiculously helpful,
you know,
and,
and so then you know,
if people mistreat you,
you see this with anti social kids,
it's very tragic thing to see because if
you're an antisocial child,
by the time you were about four,
you're very hostile and distrustful to
people.
And so you'd like a growling puppy.
And if you're a growling puppy,
tend not to get petted,
you're more likely to get kicked.
And if you're growling puppy and you get
kicked,
then you have even more reason to grow.
And that's sort of the story of
antisocial kids.
If they're not well socialized by the
time they're four and they're more on
the aggressive side than they alienate
themselves from the community.
And all they get is rejection while and
then they look at the rejection and they
think,
well
hell with humanity,
you know,
and no wonder they think that.
But,
but the part of the catastrophe is that
they get what they evoke.
And,
and I'm not saying it's their fault
precisely,
but it doesn't matter.
That's still what happens.
And so you might ask yourself,
if you're not getting from people what
you need,
there is some possibility that you're
not approaching,
especially if this happens to you
repeatedly across people.
And this is a virtual certainty.
If it happens to you repeatedly across
people,
especially if you have the same bad
experience with people,
it's not them,
it's you.
I would say three is the limit.
If something happens to you,
once
you write it off,
if it happens to you twice,
it's like you open your eyes but you
write it off.
But if it harms tier three times,
it's probably you.
Or is the rest of the world better?
It's you because you're not going to
change the rest of the world.
And he lifted up his eyes and looked.
And Lo three men stood by him.
And when he saw them,
he ran to meet them from the tent door
and bowed himself to the ground and
said,
my Lord,
if now I have found favor in thy sight,
pass,
not away.
I pray thee from Thy Servant.
Let a little water.
I Pray You be fetched and wash your
feet.
Wash your feet.
Take the dust from your feet,
extract yourself out from your journey,
right and sit.
I'll fetch a morsel of bread and comfort
ye your hearts after that you can pass
on for therefore are you come to your
servant and they said so do as thou hast
said,
and Abraham hastened into the tent,
into the tent under Sarah and said,
make ready quickly.
Three measures of fine meal,
knead it and make cakes upon the earth.
Powerful call to hospitality here,
and Abraham ran onto the herd and
fetched a calf tender and good and gave
it to a young man and he hasted to dress
it and he took butter and milk and the
calf which he had dressed and set it
before them and he stood by them under
the tree and they did eat some
commentary from here.
Hebrews 13,
to be not forgetful to entertain
strangers for thereby some have
entertained angels unawares.
This is a commentary from Matthew Henry,
who is a nonconformist minister and
author,
cheerful and obliging.
Manners in showing kindness are great.
Ornaments to piety.
There are condescending,
Lord Vouch,
safest,
not personal visits to us,
yet still by his spirit,
he stands at the door and knocks.
When we're inclined to open,
he deigns to enter by his gracious
constellations.
He provides a rich feast of which we
partake with him.
This is from revelations 3:20.
Behold,
I stand at the door and knock.
If any man hear my voice and open the
door,
I will come into him and will sup with
him and he with me.
Well,
the hyperlink nature of those quotes is
quite obvious.
There's 10 or 15 things being said at
the same time,
right?
One is a reference to the idea that if
you ask for something,
it will be given to you.
Right?
It was a very strange idea,
but I like that idea a lot and I believe
my,
in my experience,
that has been true.
If it was that I wanted what I was
asking for because that's the real
issue,
right?
Because the question is if you want
something,
what does it mean to want it?
And what it means is to sacrifice
whatever is necessary to get it because
otherwise you don't want it.
And so there's an equation here,
and I'm not claiming it's ultimate
accuracy,
but the equation is something like you
don't want it unless you're willing to
sacrifice for it.
And if you don't want it,
you're not going to get it because
you're scattered.
But if you do want at any make the
proper sacrifices,
then
God only knows what might happen.
And that's a c.
One of the things I really like about
the existential philosophers is their
emphasis on personal responsibility.
Many of them had an emphasis on the role
that people had in shaping their own
destiny.
The exits for the existentialists.
And I think this was a consequence of
the religious substructure,
of,
of philosophical thinking.
It was self evident that life was tragic
and bitter,
but,
and then fair enough,
but that isn't where it ended.
The next issue was,
well,
there are better in ways,
better and worse ways of dealing with
that.
And the better way of dealing with the
fact that life is tragic and better is
to pause it,
the self you could be and live
authentically in relationship to that.
And then the next issue and some this is
something kierkegaard talked about,
particularly when he talked about the
necessity of being a knight of faith,
is that the thing is,
and this is I think part of the light
part of life that's the intractable
adventure.
No one can take the adventure of life
away from you,
that they can't do it with good advice,
for example,
because no one can demonstrate to you
that if you straighten yourself out a
name at what you want and make the
proper sacrifices that your life will
turn out in the manner that you might
want it to turn out.
It isn't in anyone else's purview to
make that judgment.
The only person that can possibly figure
that out is you.
It's something that can't be stolen from
you.
I would say it's your destiny.
It's a destiny that cannot be stolen
from you and you can forgo it.
You can say,
well,
I'm not willing to put in the effort
because what if I fail?
Well,
first of all,
if you don't put in the effort,
you will fail because life is hard and
it takes everything out of you to do it
properly so you will fail and if you
make the proper sacrifices,
you might fail.
That's why I like the ambiguity and the
story of Cain and Abel because we're
never really told why God rejected
Kane's offerings.
There's hands that came maybe isn't
doing as good a job as he should,
and he certainly gets bitter about it,
but there's no smoking pistol.
It doesn't say,
well,
Cain is a bad guy.
He made terrible sacrifices,
so god rejected him.
You never know.
Cain might've been working pretty damn
hard and things still didn't work out
for them,
and I think that ambiguity is
appropriate in the story because that
ambiguity ambiguity is in life.
You'd be.
You'd be a fool to say that everything
always works out for everyone if they
just do things right.
I mean,
I think that's a very.
That's a very careless thing to say,
given how much tragedy and catastrophe
there is in the world and how much of it
seems to be undeserved,
but that still has very little bearing I
think on,
on,
on your own individual adventure and the
necessity for the necessity for opening
the door to who you could be and,
and the necessity to do that.
Seriously.
And I do believe and I think I,
I think that's why this most impossible
of versus you know,
knock and the door will open.
Why that's believable is that I have
never met anyone who couldn't
hypothesize a better them in some
manner.
All they had to do is ask.
It's like,
well,
how could you be better?
Thank well here's three ways.
It's like,
it's no problem,
right?
You can think about that no time flat.
Maybe it's small ways,
but you can almost always at least think
of something stupid that you're doing
that you could quit.
And so that means that you do have this.
It's a strange thing in people that we
have this built in capacity to pause it
a higher self and then to move towards
it and maybe maybe that's part of where
the religious instinct really came from
speaking like really reductionistically
like as a materialist.
As an evolutionary psychologist,
we have this notion of the transcendent
ideal,
right?
That that seems to be pervasive across
cultures.
Well,
that's the ultimate manifestation of the
human proclivity to be able to pause it
an ideal at all and to move forward.
You pause it.
An ideal,
okay.
That you need that to move forward.
Well,
if you can pause it,
an ideal,
why can't you pause it?
The ultimate ideal?
Well,
if you can then instantly you've got a
religious sensibility instantly and so
maybe that's because I'm positive like
as a biologist,
what the hell is the basis of the
religious instinct because the idea that
it's mere superstition,
like we can just dispense with that.
That's a wrong.
It's a human universal.
You can evoke religious experiences all
sorts of ways,
so we're not going to play that game.
There's some reason that that instinct
exists and the first thing to do with it
is to try to reduce it to something
that's biological and leave it at that.
Not to mess with the metaphysics,
but it certainly could be the case that
it's the ultimate extension of our
capacity to pause it and ideal and we
also might say,
well,
that's good enough because,
the ideal moves you forward.
It fills your life with meaning.
There's no doubt about that because it
is in the movement towards your ideal
that life's meaning is to be attained.
And then the question is,
well,
how much meaning is there in moving
forward towards an ultimate ideal?
Well more meaning,
even though it's more difficult,
how much?
Well,
that's the open question.
Behold,
I will stand at the door and knock,
and if any man hear my voice and open
the door,
I will come into him and will sup with
him and he with me.
That's a pretty good deal.
And the Angel said Unto Him,
where is Sarah?
Thy Wife?
And Abraham said,
behold in the tent.
And he said,
I will certainly return unto thee
according to the time of life.
And Lo,
Sarah,
thy wife shall have a son,
and Sarah heard it in the tent door,
which was behind him.
Now Abraham and Sarah were old and well
stricken in age,
and it had ceased to be with Sarah after
the manner of women.
Therefore,
Sarah laughed within herself saying,
after I am waxed old,
shall I also have this pleasure,
my lord being old also.
Well,
she's kind of skeptical about the whole
Angel Man,
God having a child at 100 thing.
And,
and,
and rightly so.
Rightly so.
And the Lord said Unto Abraham,
why did Sarah Laugh saying,
shall I have a sorority bear,
a child which am old,
is anything too hard for the Lord at the
time appointed,
I will return unto thee according to the
time of life and Sarah shall have a son.
Then Sarah denied saying,
I left not for.
She was afraid and he said Nay,
but though did slough
and the men rose up from dance and look
toward Sodom.
And Abraham went with them to bring them
on the way.
I'm going to make a small detour and
talk to you about this idea of potential
again because it's really,
really thought about it a lot.
I think music speaks of potential,
like I think music speaks of potential
bursting forward.
It's something.
It's something like that and that's why
it's so deeply meaningful and it's this
continual pattern revelation of of the
next wonderful thing that might happen.
It's something like that.
So there's that and people find that
deeply meaningful and then there's the
idea that we all have potential that
isn't realized,
but that we regard that potential even
though it's not realized as real,
which I can't get my head around at all.
It just doesn't make sense.
And then although everyone acts that way
and everyone believes it because white,
what you act reflects what you believe
and you make judgments about yourself
and others based on those beliefs and
their deep judgements.
So the idea that you believe that there
is such a thing as human potential,
I think.
I think it's undeniable if you act at
all,
if you expect things of people at all,
then you're demonstrating your
commitment to the idea of potential,
but then I wonder if there's something
even deeper going on because we are very
materialistic,
modern people and there's great power in
that.
Obviously we've obtained great control
over the material world for better or
for worse,
but we do have a tendency to think of
the world purely as a material structure
and he isn't really obvious to me that
the world is exactly a material
structure.
It seems to be to be something more like
constrained potential know because
everything is a certain way,
but everything that is a certain way
could be a multitude of other ways and
almost an infinite multitude of other
ways and the degree to which something
that is could be a multitude of other
ways is dependent on large part on how
you interact with it.
Right.
Even with materials that were very
familiar with,
we continue to discover new properties
and put them to use.
It's like things are.
Things are compacted into their material
form,
but that doesn't exhaust what they are,
especially not in relationship to other
things and so it seems to me even if you
can't replace the materialist
perspective with the perspective that
it's better to construe the world
construe being as if it's made of
possibility rather than the world as if
it's made of matter.
It's at least useful to have that as an
additional viewpoint.
Is that because you could say,
well the material philosophy is very
useful as a tool for obtaining certain
sorts of benefits,
which it clearly is,
but then this more metaphysical
perspective,
which I think is more accurate in some
ways that the world is a place of
potential is also an extraordinarily
useful way to approach the world and and
it is practically useful.
You know what we talked last week a
little bit about doing something as
simple as trying to organize a room.
It's,
it's by no means obvious how much
potential there is in a room,
right?
There's a very large amount of potential
in any given room.
Tremendous amount of potential,
especially if it's connected with people
and maybe an inexhaustible amount of
potential and maybe there's an
inexhaustible amount of potential
everywhere and that we just don't know
how to get access to it on.
That's certainly true.
I mean,
it's certainly true to some degree.
We don't know how to get access to all
the potential of our children,
for example,
or ourselves or our loved ones or it or,
or the people that we know so well.
So I think the story is trying to hammer
that idea home to which is
don't be so sure that it's impossible or
maybe don't let the assumption that's
it.
It's impossible.
Stop you from going forth into the
world.
That would be.
And that's a,
that's uh,
what would you say that's like an
inoculation against nihilism.
And I'm,
for a long time I understood nihilism
very well.
I could,
I could understand its rationale
associated with the tragedy of life
associating with suffering and evil
associated with the observation of
finitude and the arbitrary and unjust
nature of the world.
But the more I've thought about it,
the less I've come to believe that
there's any excuse for it whatsoever.
And I think the reason for that is that
it forestalls effort.
It forestalls the ability to discover
for yourself maybe there's no reason to
be so God damn hopeless except that it's
easier to be useless now.
And believe me,
I'm not making that case.
I'm not saying that that's what's be
setting people who are clinically
depressed,
for example.
That's not my point.
Clinical depression is a terrible thing.
There's lots of reasons to be rendered
to be,
to be tossed into a catastrophic
condition that isn't what I mean.
I mean that kind of cynical,
arrogant,
rational,
hyper-intelligent nihilism that throws
the world away as if it's of little use
before it's been properly engaged,
with
better to engage with it and see what
happens and better to make the
assumption that if the world isn't
returning to you,
what it is that you need,
then are either you're not doing it
right or you've conceptualized what you
need badly.
Why not at least open yourself up to
that possibility,
right?
Because you could be wrong.
Hopefully,
if you're suffering,
this is a great thing to know.
Hopefully if you're suffering,
you're wrong,
because if you're suffering and you're
right,
then there's nowhere to go,
so it's very useful to find out whatever
errors you might be committing.
Another thing that's really interesting
about the Jews in the Old Testament,
it's a remarkable thing.
Every single time they get flattened by
God,
it's always their fault.
They never say,
the world that God created was
corrupted.
God is evil.
They never say that.
No matter what happens,
right,
no matter what catastrophe occurs,
when they have every reason to at least
put that hypothesis
forward,
they don't.
They say,
we aired,
we walked off the path.
It's our fault,
and that's hard,
you know,
because it.
It puts all the weight of human
catastrophe on the human being.
That's very hard,
but the upside is it gives you the
control.
It opens up the door that it opens up
the possibility that you could be the
person that could set it right.
If you would just let go of what's in
your way,
whatever that is,
and the men rose up from thence and look
toward Sodom,
and Abraham went with them to bring them
on the way and the Lord said,
shall I hide from Abraham?
That thing which I'm about to do.
Seeing that Abraham shall surely become
a great mighty nation and all the
nations of the Earth shall be blessed in
him.
I guess God is talking to himself here
or maybe he's talking to the angels,
but I think he's trying to make a
decision for I know him,
that he will command his children and
his household after him and they shall
keep the way of the Lord to do justice
and judgment that the Lord may bring
upon Abraham that which he has spoken of
him and the Lord said,
because of the cry of Sodom and Gomorrah
is great,
and because of their sin is very
grievous.
I will go down now and see whether they
have done altogether according to the
cry of it,
which has come to me.
And if not,
I will know.
Well,
we don't know what's happened in Sodom
and Gomorrah,
but we know that God's got wind of it
and that that's not good and we know
that sin means to miss the mark,
and so we know that whatever has
happened in Sodom and Gomorrah means
that something about the natural ethical
order of things has been seriously
violated and there's a strong intimation
in the Old Testament,
which I think by the way,
is completely correct.
That if the proper order of being is
violated and that's something like the
balance between chaos and order,
say if the proper balance of being is
violated,
then all hell will break loose.
And one of the things I can tell you
from reading a very,
from reading a very comprehensive set of
myths from around the world is that
that's a conclusion that human beings
have come to everywhere.
Stay on the God Damn Path and be careful
because if you start to mess around and
you deviate,
especially if you know that you're
deviating,
things are not going to go well for you.
And that idea is everywhere.
And I think it's right.
I think the idea is right because there
aren't that many ways of doing things
right and there's a lot of ways of doing
things wrong and if you do things wrong,
the consequences of doing them wrong can
be truly catastrophic.
You know,
one of the things I learned from reading
Victor Frankl first,
but then Aleksandr Solzhenitsyn,
who I think did a deeper job was that
Vaclav Havel thought the same thing,
that these people were very much trying
to understand what happened in places
like Nazi Germany and in the Soviet
Union Solzhenitsyn's Gulag archipelago.
Calico is a particularly good analysis
of what happened in the Soviet Union and
his conclusion and it's a 2100 page
conclusion and it's like hammered home
with a hammer.
It's,
it's a book that everyone should read,
you know,
assuming that you can read at 2100 page
scream because that's basically what it
is.
You know,
first of all,
what he does is document just how
terrible things were in the Soviet Union
between 19,
19 in 1959.
And no matter how terrible you think
they were,
unless you know the stories,
they were a lot more terrible than that,
and they were terrible personally
because everyone lied.
They were terrible in families because
two out of five people were government
informers.
They were terrible among friends because
no one could tell each other the truth.
They were terrible socially because the
whole system was corrupt and ban on
slave labor and they were terrible
philosophically because the doctrine of
man upon which the state was founded was
hopeless and nihilistic and they were
murderous,
destructive and genocidal.
It's like they got it wrong at every
single level of analysis simultaneously.
And the question is why?
And Solzhenitsyn's answer,
and to some degree Victor Frankel's
answer as well.
And Vaclav Havel and I would say also
Nelson Mandela and Gandhi,
they all,
they all ended up in the same conceptual
sphere.
And the answer was because individual
people lived crooked lives because
individual people swallowed lies and
spoke them and didn't stand up for the
truth.
And the corruption that spread from each
individual pulled the entire state
mechanism into that corruption and made
everything into hell.
You know,
there are other theories,
a bed once,
right?
That's kind of the milgrim idea from
that.
It's easy to make human beings obd,
obedient to people in authority.
And I've explored that idea quite a bit
with regards to what happens happen,
for example,
in the Nazi concentration camps.
And yes,
you can set circumstances up so that
people are likely to be obedient to
orders that are pathological.
There's no doubt about that.
And yes,
sometimes that's indicative of the
weakness of their character,
but that's not the issue.
And the idea that what happened in Nazi
Germany was because uh,
uh,
population of good people listened to a
tiny minority of bad people.
That's a really how it's really not a
good theory.
The,
the Nazi ethos was there at every single
level of the social organization,
right?
Right from the personal,
right,
from the personal,
from the familial,
all the way up to the leadership.
It was the same thing all the way up and
all the way down and the same thing in
the Soviet Union.
And so we're also,
if you miss the mark,
which is apparently what the people of
Sodom and Gomorrah,
he had,
their sin was grievous,
then they risk destruction and I just
cannot see how after the 20th century,
anybody with any sense could possibly
not see that as true.
And I think that there's a line in the
Old Testament,
you know that the fear of God is the
beginning of wisdom.
I can tell you one of the things that
frightened me badly was the realization
from reading soldier nets and under a
variety of other things that I was
reading at the same time that Dostoevsky
as well because he makes the same point.
He said that a human being is not only
responsible for everything they do,
but for everything that everyone else
does,
now you know that's crazy.
And he was an epileptic and a mystic.
And that's a crazy thing to say,
but it's also.
There's something about it that's true.
Because if you were better,
the people around you would be less
worse than they are.
And if you were good enough,
you don't know how much better the
people around you would be.
And so there's this idea to,
you know that Christ took the sins of
the world unto himself.
That's a complicated idea,
Matt.
I wrestled with that one for a very long
time,
but I think I figured out,
at least in part what it means.
It meant that
it's something like the realization of
complete humanity you see,
to take the sins of the world onto
yourself is to realize that it's to
understand the Nazi concentration camp
guard,
because that person is human and so are
you.
And so if you can't see you in that,
then you don't know who you are.
And if you can see you in that,
well,
then you've started to take the sins of
the world onto yourself because you've
actually started to take responsibility
for those terrible things.
You know,
I think it's the Motif of the motto of
the Holocaust Museum in Washington.
We must never forget.
That's close.
And I think,
well,
you can't forget,
you can't remember what you don't
understand.
You will forget what you don't
And the question is,
well,
what are you supposed to remember about
the Holocaust?
It was a historical event that 6 million
people died.
That's not.
What's to remember,
wants to remember is that's what people
can do,
and you're one of them.
And if you don't understand that you
could do that,
then you don't know who you are.
Thank you.
So go ahead to making a case here.
He's making a case that the people of
Sodom and Gomorrah have sinned,
and it's making a large
rackets that even God has heard about.
That's a very common mythological motif
by the way,
that the sins and,
and,
and what would you call it?
The sins and noise of humanity can read
such a clamor that even the gods here in
and are forced to intervene.
That comes all the way from the
Mesopotamian creation story.
So anyways,
it's logical.
Yeah,
they're sending.
Okay,
well,
so what?
Well,
no,
not so wide.
It means that God's offended and that
everything is at risk.
That's what it means.
It's like that's something worth taking.
Seriously.
The men turned their faces from thence
and went towards Sodom,
but Abraham stood yet before the Lord
and Abraham drew near and said,
will thou also destroy the righteous
with the wicked?
This is a very interesting part of the
story.
A friend of mine took me to task the
other day when I was writing about
portraying the old testament.
God is pretty harsh and judgmental and
the New Testament God is sort of all
loving,
which,
which he isn't because there's the whole
book of revelations thing.
But um,
but I got that partly from reading
northrop Frye,
but going through the old testament more
detail,
I realized that that's,
that is too low resolution
interpretation and that God who is
dispensing a fair bit of harsh justice
in the old testament is also someone who
can be negotiated with weirdly enough.
And that's what happens here.
You know,
Abraham has just been told that
whatever's going on in Sodom and
Gomorrah is seriously not good and that
God's going to do something about it.
And he takes it upon himself.
This is an act of mercy to to ask God to
be a bit more judicious,
right?
It's like,
okay,
you're gonna.
Wipe out the city.
Well,
bad things are happening there,
but you know,
there's probably a few people in the
damn city that aren't completely
corrupted by what's going on there.
Of course,
that's an open question,
you know,
because it's an open question.
For example,
how many people were there were in Nazi
Germany who weren't completely corrupted
by what was going on in Nazi Germany and
the same thing could be said about China
and the same thing could be said about
the Soviet Union.
It's like,
well,
perhaps there was a person somewhere who
didn't understand at some level what was
happening,
but you know,
the whole issue of willful blindness
certainly springs to mind if nothing
else.
Anyways,
Abraham decides to intercede with God on
behalf of these people who are going to
be destroyed.
He says,
will also destroy the righteous with the
wicked.
Perhaps there'll be 50 righteous people
within the city will you will also
destroy and not spare the place for the
50 righteous that are there that that'd
be far from the to do after this manner.
He's Kinda reminding God that he's a
good guy as far as I can tell,
to slay the righteous with the wicked
and the righteous should be as the
wicked be far from the should not the
judge of the Earth do right?
And the Lord said,
if I find in Sodom,
50 right,
he seems a bit taken aback here to me.
If I find in Sodom,
50 righteous within the city,
then I will spare the place for their
sakes.
And Abraham answered and said,
behold,
now
I have taken upon me to speak upon the
Lord unto the Lord,
which,
but I am,
but dust and ashes possibly there shall
lack five of the 50 righteous will.
They'll destroy all the city for lack of
five.
And he said,
he said,
God said,
if I find they're 45,
I will not destroy it.
And Abraham spoke unto him yet again and
said,
he's kind of sneaking up on God here
peradventure there shall be 40 found
there.
And he said,
I will not do it for 40 sake.
And he said unto him,
Oh,
let the Lord not be angry and I will
speak possibly there shall be 30 found
there.
And God said,
I won't do it if I find 30 there.
And Abraham who seems really to be
pushing his luck by this point,
says,
behold,
I have taken upon me to speak unto the
Lord,
possibly there shall be found there.
And God said I won't destroy it for
[inaudible] Sake.
And he said,
Oh,
let the Lord not be angry and I will
speak yet,
but this once perhaps 10 shall be found
there.
And he said,
I will not destroy it for 10 sick.
And the Lord went his way in.
As soon as he had left communing with
Abraham and Abraham returned unto his
place.
Well,
there's two ways you can read that part
of the story.
One is that three,
let's say you can bargain with God even
if you're kind of annoying about it.
So that's kind of interesting.
The second is that even if there's a
minority of good in a place that isn't
good,
it won't be slated for destruction.
That's kind of a good thing.
And the third is a minority of good in a
place can keep it from being destroyed.
And that's a really good thing too.
And I believe that as well.
I think that good is more powerful than
evil naivety isn't.
But I think that good is.
And I think that in a place that's
corrupt,
a minority of people who stand forth
against the corruption can prevail.
Now,
you know,
I think,
I think one of the best examples of that
again was Alexander Solzhenitsyn because
he was in the terrible work camps when
he wrote his book.
He memorized most of it,
which is not an easy thing to do when
it's 2100 pages long and set and very
tiny font.
And he memorized most of it.
And then he wrote it and it was one of
the things that brought down the Soviet
Union.
You know,
it was published in the 19 seventies.
First of all,
in we're in the west and the first thing
that happened,
at least initially was that the
communism as an ethical system last
absolutely all credibility whatsoever
among anyone who is even vaguely
educated immediately upon the
publication of the Gulag archipelago.
He pulled the moral slots out from
underneath it and the book was
definitely one of the.
There were many,
but
it was definitely one of the reasons why
the rotten system crumbled and fell
without a war.
And that's a great example of how one
person can take on a tyranny and
prevail.
So and he's not the only person who did
that sort of thing because what Gandhi
did,
the same thing.
I mean,
I don't think the English were the
Russians,
but things were not so good in India and
what Gandhi did in India under the
influence by the way of Leo Tolstoy was
also a remarkable example of a single
person intervening in,
in catastrophe and,
and setting it far more right than it
could be.
So,
and there came two angels to Sodom at
evening and lot.
Remember lot is Abraham's nephew sat in
the gate of Sodom and lot seeing them
rose up to meet them and he bowed
himself with his face toward the ground
and he said,
behold my lords turn in.
I pray you into your servant's house and
Tarry all night and wash your feet and
you shall rise up early and go on your
ways.
Oh,
he's Abraham's nephew and kinsmen and
acting in exactly the manner that
Abraham does.
He shows hospitality to these people and
they said,
no,
we'll stay in the street all night,
and he insisted.
He pressed upon them greatly and they
turned in unto him and entered into his
house and he made them a feast and baked
on leaving bread and they did eat,
but before they lay down the men of the
city,
even the men of Sodom Compas the house
round,
both old and young,
all the people from every quarter and
they called into lot and said unto him,
where are the men which came into the
this night?
Bring them out to us that we may know
them
well.
That's
the part of the story that's been used
as
diatribe,
let's say,
against homosexuality because to know is
to engage in sexual intercourse and the
inhabitants of Sodom and Gomorrah were
willing to care for strangers out of
lot's house and use and abuse them as
they see fit.
Right,
and so what are they doing?
Well,
they're violating the principle,
the principles that govern appropriate
conduct with a stranger,
and maybe the stranger is something you
shouldn't mess with because you don't
know who you're messing with.
So that's like warning number one,
while they're violent and they're
violating the essential principles of
hospitality,
and then there's the sexual thing here I
think is isn't the sexual thing.
Here is something more like the absolute
danger of immediate gratification,
sexual included outside the constraints
of any civilized structure whatsoever,
right?
Because that's as uncivilized behavior
as you could possibly hope for,
right?
Strangers come into your city,
they're in the house of someone who's
part of your city.
They're being shown hospitality.
A mob shows up and says,
for,
come over man,
we're going to do whatever the hell we
want to them and it's not going to be
good,
and if you get in the way,
things are going to go even worse for
you.
So,
so that's what it seems to me to be.
It's completely dysregulated behavior.
It's behavior that's outside the,
the confines of any civilized structure
whatsoever.
It's an indic.
It's an indication that the insight into
the social structure of the entire
society has collapsed so that there's
nothing left for the inhabitants to do
except to engage in the most brutal of
immediate gratification and destruction.
Well,
so what does he do?
I pray the brethren do not do so.
Wickedly behold,
now I have two daughters which have not
yet known.
Man,
let me.
I pray you bring them out onto you and
you do to them is as good and your eyes
only unto these men do nothing.
And therefore for therefore came they
the under the shadow of my roof.
Well,
it's hard to know what to make of that.
You know?
I mean,
it doesn't exactly seem like the
advisable thing for a lot to do
and
but I think at least what it is is an
indication of the degree to which he
took the solemn vow of hospitality
seriously.
And I think that's the idea that the
story is trying to promote.
And the angel said,
stand back.
Oh.
And the man said,
stand back.
And they said again,
this one fellow came into sojourn to
talk to us and he will need to be a
judge.
Now.
We'll deal worse with him than with
them.
And they press sore upon the man even
lot and came near to break the door.
Maybe what lot thought was something
like,
well,
we're,
we're done.
We're all done with this mop and perhaps
I can spare some of us.
And they press sore upon the man even
loud and came near to break the door.
But the man this is the angels put forth
their hand and a lot into the host to
them and shut the door.
And they smote the men that were at the
door of the house with blindness,
both small and great so that they
wearied themselves to find the door so
they were so corrupt that they were
blind and could not see now even to find
the door.
And the man said unto lot has thou here
any besides any family member's son in
law,
and they sons and my daughters and
whoever thou hast in the city,
get them out of the place for we will
destroy this place because of the cry of
them is wax and great before the face of
the Lord.
And the Lord has sent us to destroy it
and lot went out and spake unto his sons
law.
Yeah.
Which married his daughters and said,
up you get out of this place,
for the Lord will destroy the city.
But he seemed as one that marked unto
his sons,
sons in law from in the morning arose
then the angels hastened,
blot,
saying,
arise.
Take thy wife and my two daughters which
are here,
lest thou be consumed in the iniquity of
the city.
And while he lingered,
lingered,
the men laid hold upon his hands and
upon the hand of his wife and upon the
hand of his two daughters,
the Lord Being Merciful unto him and
they brought him forth and set him
without the city.
So he's still.
This is an indication of the danger of
not acting with appropriate haste.
When the time has come,
I mean lots already seen what happened.
He saw that the men came to his door,
he saw that they were murderers,
rapists.
He saw that the angels took them out and
he's still hesitant to leave that place.
And so I guess one of the things that
this story requires people to ask
themselves is,
are you in a place that's so bad that
you should leave?
Or when are you in a place that's so bad
that you should leave?
And if you are in a place that's so bad
that you should leave,
then the time to leave is now because
there's no time to waste.
And it came to pass when they had
brought them forth abroad that he said,
escape for the life.
Look not behind you.
Neither stay vow and all the plain
escape to the mountain lest thou be
consumed,
and Lord said to them,
oh,
not not so my Lord,
behold now they serve and have found
grace in my sight and now has magnified
thy mercy,
which though has showed me into saving
my life,
but I cannot escape to the mountain,
less some evil take me and I die.
Behold now there's a city near to flee
unto and it's a little one,
which means maybe it's not big and
corrupt like Sodom and Gomorrah.
Oh,
let me escape thither is it?
Is it not a little one?
And my soul shall live.
Matthew Henry said,
lot linger.
He trifled thus many who are under
convictions about their spiritual state
and the necessity of a changed differ
that needful work.
And he said unto him,
see,
I've accepted the angel,
and he said unto him,
see,
I have accepted the concerning this
thing also that I will not overthrow
this city for the which thou has spoken
to small city,
hasty escape feather for.
I cannot do anything to allow gone
hither.
Therefore,
the name of the city was Zaur.
That's where Laura went at,
the sun was rezoned upon the earth wind,
lot entered into [inaudible],
then the Lord rained upon Sodom and
Gomorrah,
brimstone and fire from the Lord out of
Heaven,
and he overthrew the cities and all the
plane and all the inhabitants of the
cities and that which grew up on the
ground,
but his wife looked back from behind him
and she became a pillar of salt,
known histology for catastrophe.
I think what that means is that when you
leave what's not good,
you wash the dust off your feet and you
don't look back,
and that's a very harsh lesson.
This is accurate.
A bit in the New Testament,
the idea of the necessity for immediate
action.
These are some of the harsher words that
Christ said.
This is from Matthew Eight.
Christ is addressing a multitude and
asking people to follow him,
and a disciple comes up to him and says,
Lord,
suffer me first to go and bury my
father.
Seems like a perfectly reasonable
request,
but Jesus said unto him,
follow me,
and let the dead bury their dead.
This is from Matthew 12.
Well,
he had talked to the people,
behold his mother and his brethren stood
without desiring to speak with him.
Then one said to him,
behold,
thy mother and I,
brethren,
stand without desiring to speak with
the.
But Jesus answered the one who was
telling him and said,
who is my mother and who is my brother's
for whosoever shall do the will of my
father,
which is in heaven,
the same as my brother and sister and
mother.
Well,
what does all that mean?
It means that there's no excuses
whatsoever for not getting up and
getting out it.
That's what it means.
And it means that
it even means that when people are beset
with a catastrophe,
like let's say the death of their
father,
that they are prone to use that as an
excuse for not going about the business
that they should be going about because
they can say to themselves,
well,
I would except,
and except there's always good reasons.
I mean,
believe me,
there's always good reasons for not
doing what you should know.
It's for sure the reasons pile up day
after day to not do what you should,
especially cause you're,
you're aiming at things in the future.
You can put them off and definitely
right because of the demands of the day,
but these stories,
they say a variety of things,
you know,
and especially in combination.
They say when you leave somewhere
terrible,
do not look back.
There's known astrologer that's,
that's the letting the dead parts of
yourself go and then if you're going to
follow the good,
there's no excuse not to do it and that
means no excuse whatsoever under any
circumstances.
And then it's taken even farther with
regards to familial relationships,
it is.
You can't even let them stand in your
way.
And I think that's all true and I think
I've seen virtually all of that in my
clinical practice.
Like there is no excuse whatsoever for
not getting at what it is that you
should be doing.
And I think there's something else
that's going on here,
especially in the new testament stories
which has even made maybe worse,
which is it's absolutely to justify your
inaction with a catastrophe that
extracts mercy from other people.
Right?
There's a tricky,
tricky game that's going well,
of course I can't do that.
Look at the terrible thing that's just
happened to me and say,
okay,
I understand you're absolved of any
necessity to move forward because of
your current catastrophe.
It's like,
well,
actually you're not,
and it's rather rude of you to use it as
an excuse and it's certainly
counterproductive.
And Abraham got up early in the morning
to the place where he stood before the
Lord and he looked toward Sodom and
Gomorrah,
and toward the land of the plane and
behold,
and low,
the smoke of the country went up as a
smoke,
have a furnace,
and it came to pass.
When God destroyed the cities of the
plain that God remembered Abraham and
sent lot out of the midst of the
overthrow,
when he overthrew the cities in which
lot dwelled and lot went out of
[inaudible] and dwelt in the mountain.
And his two daughters with him for he
filler feared to dwell in Zuora and he
dwelt in a cave.
He and his two daughters and the
firstborn said unto the younger her
father was,
and there's not a man in the earth to
come in to us after the manner of all
the earth.
Come let us make our father drink wine
and we will lie with him that we may
preserve the seed of our father
and they made their father drink wine
that night in the firstborn went in and
lay with her father and he perceived not
when she laid down Norwin sheet rows and
it came to pass on the morrow that the
firstborn said unto the younger,
behold I lay yesterday night with my
father.
Let us make him drink wine this night
also,
and gold out in and lie with him that we
may preserve seat of our father.
And they made their father drink wine
that night also.
And the younger a and lay with him.
And he perceived not when she laid down
Norwin,
she arose that us,
we're both the daughters of lot with
child by their father.
Well,
it's like the story,
you know,
the stories outlined the catastrophe of
Sodom and Gomorrah,
essentially the ethical catastrophe of
the disillusion of the civilized
constraints that should regulate all
behavior and then the city is destroyed,
but there's an echo of it afterwards,
right?
Because law,
it had lived in Sodom and Gomorrah and
what happens to him even after his
escapes is that he gets tangled into an
incestuous web,
and so I think that that's a.
it's not foreshadowing,
it's post shadowing if there's such a
thing.
It's an echo of of what?
It's an echo and a reminder of how
terrible whatever it was that was
happening in Sodom and Gomorrah was that
even after escaping,
the inequity still remained
well.
That's a pretty good place to stop.
We got through two of three stories,
so that's not too bad.
Next week I'll talk about the sacrifice
of Isaac and see if I can get into the
next stories as well.
And next week is the last lecture,
except I talked to the theater people
and it looks like I'll be able to rent
the theater once a month at least for
the next four months.
So I'm going to do that and all
announced when I'm going to do that and
I'll continue doing this probably as
long as you all continue to come and
listen.
Thank you.
I could tell you something cool that
happened too if you want.
So some of you may know that there was a
memo leaked at Google.
How many of you know about that?
How you.
So a colleague of the man who released
the memo got ahold of me yesterday and
said that the man who wrote the memo
wanted to talk to me.
So I interviewed him today.
I made a youtube video out of it.
We went over his memo,
which was scientifically accurate in my
estimation,
and so I'm going to release that
hopefully tonight,
so we'll see how that goes.
Thank you.
He got fired last night.
A right.
He got fired for perpetuating gender
stereotypes.
He told me today that his last
performance review,
he had been given superb,
which is the top few percentiles of the
employee distribution at Google,
right.
Perpetuating gender stereotypes.
I went through his document.
I don't think he said a single thing
that wasn't substantiated by a fairly
dense scientific literature.
Not to say that the scientific
literature is necessarily 100 percent
correct because it never is,
but certainly to say that he was not
merely spouting out misogynistic and
ethnically biased opinion.
Quite the contrary.
So we had a nice discussion about that
today and hopefully the discussion will
continue.
So.
Alright,
questions.
Hello?
Well,
it's great.
I mean look at a couple of things about
that.
I mean,
my,
my daughter has had a catastrophic life
in many ways.
A lot of things went wrong with her
physically really bad things and this
went perfectly,
so like,
thank God.
Thank you.
So then,
and then the other thing
is I love kids now infants,
well you know,
it's not that I,
it's not.
Infants are cool and interesting,
but I'm not sure exactly what to do with
them,
but once they're about six months old
and then from then on,
like I love having kids around so I'm
thrilled about the fact that this has
happened,
so hooray.
Hooray.
So thanks for.
Yeah,
so more as an aside,
but what you said about not pushing
aside of the things that day kind of
made me think of Nike's motto.
Just do it.
I thought cool.
But my question was that when you were
talking about circumcision being a
contractual relationship between
sacrifice and compared it to a girl
having a period.
That didn't make a lot of sense to me,
but also it seems to me that it being a
sacrifice requires some form of
willingness basically from the one
having certain decisions that don't
necessarily want to put forward what you
didn't.
You said you specifically didn't want to
address as two infants not having any
choice in the matter,
but more in the context of it being a
sacrifice.
How does that.
I think,
I think that's how a modern person would
see it and I think that there is some,
I think there's some utility in that,
but,
but it's,
it's,
it's an incomplete,
incomplete to some degree,
you know,
because one of the things that happens
with God and Abraham is that God tells
Abraham that he has take care of his
family,
his children.
Now the question is exactly how do you
take care of your children?
And the answer is sometimes you make
decisions for them.
Now you might say,
well,
it'd be better if they could make the
decisions for themselves and that's
actually the case.
So you might say,
well,
I won't bring my kids to church because
it'd be better if they could make the
decision for themselves.
And that's what I did with my kids,
you know,
but I'm not so sure that it was a good
idea.
And the reason I'm not so sure it was a
good idea was because there are a bunch
of things they didn't learn.
Now the degree to which your parents
should exercise control over his or her
child is indeterminant.
But I guess the hope is that you
exercise the minimum amount of control
necessary to maximize the child's
probability of success,
and that certainly requires adopting
responsibility for making decisions as
well because the child can't make
decisions,
you know,
you can't just let the child lay there
and make decisions,
right?
That's just not going to happen.
And so you might say,
well,
Abraham has no right to impose something
like circumcision on his children and
because they an be an because it's a
sacrifice,
it's something that they should be doing
themselves.
But the problem with that is that
Abraham also has no right to abdicate
his responsibility to his children in
the name of some hypothetical merciful
illness.
And those two things have to be
balanced.
Well,
this,
according to the story,
Abraham got the balance right because of
course he's made this covenant with God.
Now exactly what that means in people's
day to day lives.
While that's a harder issue,
but I would say
I think in the modern world,
people err on the side of.
I don't know,
I think they're more likely to err on
the side of taking insufficient
responsibility for their children,
letting them be free in ways that aren't
productive.
That's how it looks to me often because
they're afraid of their children.
So that's about the best I can do with
that.
I was recently,
I've recently started reading maps of
meaning and I,
there was something in the introduction
to that story that I found,
particularly the introduction that you
wrote before you went until the,
um,
that I found particularly compelling,
I guess,
uh,
the part when you're talking about the
split that developed in your psyche when
you were,
you know,
all your,
I think you talked about one of the
earlier lecture,
I talked about it a little bit today,
a little bit today as well.
Um,
you said something in that paragraph
there that,
uh,
what you said was you have to earn the
right to identify with an idea yet
certain ideas for sure.
Certain ideas for sure.
Um,
so basically my question is how should a
young person such as myself who doesn't
have a whole lot of life experience,
uh,
like be able to read literature and
psychology and interact with,
you know,
the wisdom of culture and then
incorporate it into a structure that's
still authentically their own.
Well,
look,
I think the way you asked that question
means that you're actually doing a
pretty good job of that.
Thank you.
Well,
I mean that,
I mean that because that was a very
carefully formulated question and it was
obvious that you were actually looking
for an answer instead of trying to tell
the audience a bunch of things that you
knew,
which often happens with questions.
Right.
And so it's often,
it's very annoying for the audience to
be subject to questions like that,
right?
Because it's a form of
thank you
because it's a form of manipulation.
It's like,
well all cap this off with a question,
but actually it's a speech.
So,
so I would say you probably already know
the answer to that and,
but then I could elaborate on that a
little bit is like there are a lot of
books that people have historically
regarded as great.
You might as well start by assuming that
they're at least greater than you,
right?
And then and to approach them with that
frame of mind because even if there's
much in them that
perhaps is no longer relevant,
often less than people assume there's
much in the met will be of extreme
benefit to you and then with regards to
making the mirrors,
the kind of wisdom that you get from
great books is practical wisdom and you
act it out and so then what you do is
you try to incorporate what you learn
into your life,
into your practices,
and then if you incorporate it into your
life and your practices,
you build a bridge between you and the
great idea,
right?
Because you figured out how to manifest
itself in the conditions of your own
life.
That's something like making the
archetipal personal,
which is,
which is the right thing to do,
right?
It's the proper thing to do because that
expands your life upward and outward and
ennobles you and brings you up as well.
But so humility is part of it.
It's like approach these books as if
they have something to teach you and
then it's humility again in the second
place is don't take the ideas to
yourself until you lived the,
there'll be lots of time for that.
And besides,
you know,
even as a young person,
it's not like you have nothing to say,
but the only things that you have to say
are your things to say and it's not
necessarily that easy to figure out what
they are.
But as I said,
you did a fine job of that when you
asked the question.
So I think,
I think as far as I can tell,
you already know what to do.
So good.
Do it.
Read everything great you can get your
damn hands on.
Hello.
Dr Peterson.
So a lot of your work,
a lot of your lectures recommend the
audience tackle life with a lot of
attention and intention.
And,
uh,
you know,
in my kind of personal gateway,
drug to philosophy has been more eastern
philosophy and,
uh,
like the Bhagavad Gita and the work of
Alan Watts and a tower [inaudible] and
what I noticed,
I may be wrong,
but this is a common theme in eastern
philosophy,
which is more passive non-action.
Um,
don't make as many plans.
Uh,
I,
I wonder how you reconcile that and how
you are reconciling that because you
mentioned earlier in previous lectures
that you've read the teaching.
How do you reconcile those two different
views?
Well,
I think first that the Dao de Jing in
particular reason about inaction,
it's about minimal proper action and
it's also about minimal proper action
after a tremendous amount of sacrifice.
Right?
So the sage that speaking forth in the
Tao Te Ching has already let go of
almost everything that he needs to let
go off.
And a tremendous amount of what you're
reading in the eastern philosophies is
predicated,
I think,
at least in part on the idea of
sacrifice.
There's lots of things that you're
grabbing onto like the monkey with the
jar that's actually causing your misery.
And so sometimes letting go is the right
way of moving ahead,
but to me that ties into this idea of
sacrifice.
So now whether there's more than that,
whether there's more intentionality in
western philosophy and less
intentionality in eastern philosophy,
I'm not exactly sure one way of
mediating between those two was
formulated at least in part by Carl
young and he pointed out that the
archetypal figure for the West died at
32.
And so to some degree that outgoing,
extroverted,
let's say nature of the West is a
consequence of its youthfulness in some
sense.
It's useful ethos and that the east
Buddha died at a fairly ripe old age.
And even in the Hindu practices,
if I remember correctly,
were many Hindu temples.
There's a lot of erotic sculptures,
idea,
something like if you can't get past the
dam erotic sculptures,
it's not time to go into the temple,
but it's more than that.
It might also be that if you're young,
it's not time to get past the erotic
sculptures.
So maybe maybe there's a moving forward
into life in youth and a letting go in,
in the latter part of life.
And that's,
well,
that was [inaudible] way of mediating
between those two traditions.
I think they're tightly aligned with
regards to the importance of sacrifice.
It frequently is the case that it's your
desire mile,
let's say,
your desire that's causing your
suffering.
Right?
And so there's an emphasis in Buddhism,
even more than endowed with some,
I would say on letting go,
letting go of what's making you
miserable.
And,
but you remember the thing about Buddha
is that he got enlightened under the bow
tree,
right?
He basically stepped into the city of
God.
He stepped into Nirvana and he could
have stayed there,
but he chose to come back because he
decided that he had a responsibility to
rectify suffering in the rest of the
world.
That it was not sufficient for him to be
enlightened.
Well,
everything else was left in a state of
insufficiency and suffering.
And so I wouldn't call that inaction.
You know,
it's,
uh,
I've,
I've made the mistake myself.
It's inaction versus non-action.
I actually had to look up.
Yes,
that's good.
That's well not to read.
The Dao de Jing does a very good job of
distinguishing between those two because
non-action is the minimal necessary
action to keep the balance between order
and chaos proper,
right?
That the end in the egg and the Tao Te
Ching is very,
very emphatic about this.
You detach and you watch and when it's
time to intervene,
you intervene minimally without a lot of
arrogant self propagandized nation and
you tap and if you do that properly,
you hardly have to do it at all and it
says if you're doing nothing,
and there's.
There's great wisdom in that book.
I really liked the Tao Te Ching.
It's,
it's a remarkable document and I've seen
managers who were like that who were
really good at running their company who
did nothing but what they did well,
but first of all,
they set up people to replace them
because their idea was,
well,
if I'm a really good manager then this
place could run without me.
There's a real humility in that and then
they just kind of wandered around the
place talking to people and if there was
a bit of a problem then they just,
you know,
turn to norb 10th of a degree and the
place ran smoothly and it was as if they
were doing nothing and what they were
doing was detaching so they weren't
being buried by their current concerns.
They were watching to see what was going
on and then they were minimally
interacting and that worked like a
charm.
So I think that the,
I don't like the idea that all religious
traditions are the same because that
just makes them into like a gray mass,
but I don't see that there's any
difference there that can't be bridged.
I think as you look into the details,
the bridges become more clear.
I'll get you to speak into the
microphone,
especially when you're saying self
deprecating thing.
Let everybody hear you.
Okay.
It's my pleasure.
What's happened?
What's happened to you as a consequence?
Yeah,
yeah.
What are you seeing it that way anyways?
Well mainly,
um,
I've had,
I've had whatever you say,
right,
is something I've thought but not have
been able to,
uh,
articulate.
Right.
So it's been very helpful in that
regards and kind of saves me a lot of
time.
No.
Yup.
Good,
good,
good.
Uh,
my,
my main question is actually,
um,
something you said a couple of lectures
ago.
It was something along the lines of a
family.
I'm sorry.
I'm like,
God,
this,
the history of your family,
kind of like the sins of your family,
something like that.
Yeah,
you are,
you're facing it all the time.
Yup.
What's,
can you expand on that more?
Well,
there's this idea in the old testament
that your sins might be visited onto
your family seven generations down.
Seems kind of harsh,
but you know,
when you're confronting maybe your
father's tyrannical.
Yeah.
But you know,
maybe his father beat the hell out of
him and maybe his father's father was a
vicious alcoholic and he just bloody,
well don't know how far back that goes.
And,
and that means also you don't exactly
know what you're dealing with,
right?
To some degree you're dealing with your
father,
but only partly what you're dealing with
is the pathological paternal spirit,
something like that and that it's better
to think about that way because it
becomes an existential issue at that
point.
You know,
so you could say that while the father
has two components,
and I mean this psychologically
speaking,
there's the great father that's
beneficial and protective that organize
the society and teaches you how to speak
and has produced all these wonderful
things,
and then there's the tyrannical
oppressive part of the father,
just like there's the terrible part of
mother nature that's destructive and the
benevolent part of Mother Nature that's
wonderful and productive and you're
stuck with that,
right?
You're stuck with having to mediate
between those opposing forces,
just like you're stuck with the
adversarial part of yourself in the
heroic part of yourself and it's up to
you to set those things right.
Otherwise they propagate into the future
and it isn't.
It's a straightforward thing to say how
to set them.
Right.
There's quite a good movie about that.
Oh No,
I won't be Magnolia,
which I really love.
It's by Paul Anderson,
if I remember correctly.
I hope that's right.
A beautiful movie,
and it's about this part of.
It's about this kid whose fathers really
pushing them to be a superstar at a,
at a Quistio,
right?
He's a genius kid.
Hey,
and
the kids studies this guy named Charles
Sport.
You don't understand this movie if you
don't know this because you've got to
know about Charles fort to understand
magnolia.
Charles for was this weird old guy who
got rich with an inheritance when he was
20 and spent the rest of his life in
libraries looking up impossible things
and documenting them.
Impossible things that couldn't happen
from a scientific perspective that we're
well attested to by multiple observers
and he produced this news paper called
the 14 times,
which still runs anyways in Magnolia.
Magnolia begins with this guy who falls
out of a building and then it's shot by
a woman who misses her husband with a
rifle as he falls,
and I think she's.
She's charged with murder and the street
names have something to do with the
death sentence fall and all of that
happened,
and then in the movie there's a rain of
frogs and there are rains of frogs from
time to time.
Sometimes they're frozen,
sometimes their reins of fish.
Sometimes they're frozen.
It's like,
what the hell?
How does that happen?
Happens quite frequently.
As it turns out,
there's a rain of frogs in the,
in the movie magnolia and this little
kid see what happened to him is that
he's on stage and he ends up peeing his
pants because of the pressure basically
and humiliates himself and then there's
this reign of frogs,
which he kind of takes us a sign from
God and then he goes to his father even
he's like eight years old,
this kid,
and he says,
you have to stop doing this to me.
And He's dead serious about it.
Very careful not being,
you know,
what would you call insubordinate?
Nothing like that.
He decides that that's coming to an end
right now and you have to make those
decisions in your family because
otherwise things propagate down the
generations,
right,
and every family is rife with
pathologies of one form or another and
you can learn from that and refuse to
push it forward and that's part of I
think what you do when you,
when you,
when you shoulder your existential
burden because everyone is the
beneficiary and the victim of the
tyrannical father,
just like everyone is the beneficiary
and the victim of mother nature and of
themselves and so you lock horns without
and straighten it out one way or another
and you don't move it forward to the
next generation.
So and maybe you detach it a bit from
your parents too because
God only knows what combination of
catastrophes culminated in their
particular forms of pathology.
So good enough.
So this week we've had the google thing,
there was the youtube thing that
happened last week.
What's going on with censorship and what
should people do about it?
If you're in a workplace in
pathological,
things are happening.
This is easy.
I can tell you how you know of
pathological things are happening at
your workplace or they're happening with
you one of the two,
but you can straighten that out if
you're being required to do things that
make you weak and ashamed,
then stop.
Don't do them.
Like one of the things I learned from
Solzhenitsyn and Frankl was that
systems go terribly under,
out of control when people don't stop
them,
when they're going mildly out of
control.
You know when you might say,
I should just keep my goddamn head down
and shut up.
It's like maybe you should like,
that's not bad advice.
You know you don't want to make
unnecessary enemies and you don't need
any more trouble than you need,
but you got to ask yourself on a day to
day basis what makes you think you're
not selling your soul.
You know,
and there's so much foolishness going on
in the mid level bureaucratic world now.
That's where all the tyranny seems to be
focused and the reason that it
multiplies is because sensible people
say nothing when they should say
something.
And what's so strange about that is that
there are way more sensible people than
people who aren't sensible.
They're just not as noisy.
So what you'll turn out if like,
you know,
so let's say something's bugging the
hell out of you at work.
Well then you have to prepare it to find
another job.
That's the first thing you have to do.
I don't think that you should find
another job,
but you should prepare to find another
job.
And if possible you should prepare to
find a better job.
Because if you can't tell someone to go
to hale,
then you can't negotiate with them.
And if and if they've got you over a
barrel,
then you can't say anything.
So you gotTa,
you gotta set yourself up.
So you've got some mobility and actually
that's a really good principal in your
life,
period.
You should set yourself up so that you
have a lateral move at hand and then you
should find out,
well,
are there things at work that are
disturbing my soul?
You know,
and you find that out.
First of all,
you ask yourself,
okay,
I'm disturbed at work.
Okay,
I'm probably week and deceitful and
useless and lazy.
You might as well start with that and
then you talk to some people,
like your wife,
your friends,
your coworkers,
and find out are you stupid,
deceitful and lazy,
or is there something not so good going
on at work?
And so if you,
if you can then eliminate your own
personal pathology as a cause of your
dissatisfaction,
then maybe there's something rotten in
the state of Denmark and maybe you
should say something about it before the
whole goddamn thing collapses because
that can happen.
It can happen in companies a lot faster
than people ever think you know,
and you may find that,
well,
first of all,
you may find if you say something,
well first of all,
that's an adventure.
That's for sure.
That's a bloody adventure and you have
to do it carefully and,
and you have to be prepared for it,
but it might be the best thing that ever
happened to you.
And the other thing is if you're careful
about it,
you get your words right.
Like in,
this is a,
this is strategic battle,
right?
It's not something you wander into
carelessly.
Then you may find that there's lots of
people who feel exactly the same way you
do and that you've actually caught and
onto something.
You're a canary in a coal mine and not
just some psychopathic mouthpiece,
so you got to ask yourself,
when you go and do what you do like,
is this making you stronger?
Is this making you weaker?
And if it's making you weaker,
then you gotta ask yourself,
do you really want to be weaker?
Because the weaker you get,
the more your tyrannized and then worse
than that,
like the weaker you get,
the more bitter you get and the more
you'll work towards terrible things.
The more you'll snap it your wife,
the more you'll kick your kids.
You know,
like it's no joke to be tyrannized at
work.
And so I would say you have an ethical
responsibility as a citizen to
forthrightly confront,
creeping tyranny,
no matter where it occurs.
And part of,
part of what we're learning,
I would say from these stories,
if we're learning anything at all,
is that if you're aimed at the good,
which is a question you really got to
ask yourself,
you know,
if you're genuinely aimed at the good,
then take heart because you're a lot
stronger than you think.
So
I have a followup question,
Kate.
So I'm speaking to.
There's lots of people who were in this
situation like,
you know,
people at universities and corporations
all over the place.
I know Google is not the only company
that is not the worst repressive freedom
of speech denying workplace codes and
everybody feels alone,
right?
They're all like,
why should I stand up,
be a martyr,
get fired.
This guy at Google got fired.
Yeah.
What's the point?
I'm asking rhetorically.
No,
it's a good question.
And how do you.
How do you convince people that there's
a point to standing up when it appears
to be futile?
Well,
the first thing I think is you convince
them that it's not futile.
It might be difficult,
but it's not futile if you get your
words right,
you have something to say.
There'll be an impact of those words.
It might not be the impact that you
would choose,
but the.
But the other thing you've got to tell
people is pick your poison.
You don't.
You may be in a situation where you
don't have a.
You don't have a cake.
Walk to the garden of Paradise.
You got tyranny or famine.
Those are your choices,
but you get to pick which one you have,
and I would say if,
if you're being oppressed and I mean in
your soul by what you're required to
swallow at work,
well you think you're not paying a price
for that.
You've got no self respect and,
and,
and rightly so,
but worse than that,
you're an agent of your own destruction.
You're destroying your own ideal and
you're letting people who are weak and
corrupt when and if you stood up and
stood up properly,
but you have to put yourself in order to
do this,
at least to some degree,
right?
You can't do it casually.
You have to do it from some position of
preparedness and strength.
Then what makes you think you couldn't
scare them back into the corners and
that would be a good thing.
And you know,
the alternative personally is bad
because there's a psychological
degeneration that goes along with it.
I've seen this with many,
many of the people that I've worked with
who have been tyrannized in the
workplace to the absolute detriment of
their psychological and physical health,
right?
To the point of collapse confronting
these crazy,
crazy things when they were sensible
people.
Um,
that's a terrible price to pay man.
Like it's,
it's a bad price.
And then if the foolishness isn't dealt
with at the local level when it's still
relatively trivial,
then it will multiply until it's dealt
with at the social level.
And we're seeing signs of that already.
ANTIFA is a good sign of that,
you know,
and problems that aren't solved multiply
and soon people fight and you know,
edit,
argue,
then to fight,
unless you want to fight.
And some people want to fight and I can
understand why,
but I wouldn't recommend it because
that doesn't lead good places.
It really doesn't lead good places.
So I would say you have a duty.
Maybe that's,
that's where you stand up.
It's because you have a goddamn duty to
stand up and say,
just say what you have to say it.
You don't even have to be trying to make
a point.
Exactly.
You're trying to get something done.
It's like,
this is how it looks to me.
That's what that guy had.
Google did.
He wrote this memo and he said he.
I talked to him today.
He said,
well,
he went to a diversity training seminar.
And he thought,
no,
I don't agree with that.
And so then they asked for feedback.
So we wrote this document a month ago.
This was written a month ago.
Got No real response to it.
Well,
it bounced around inside Google until a
lot of people got interested in that.
It escaped into the outside world.
But all he was doing was,
he was told a bunch of things he didn't
think were true.
He wrote down a bunch of things he
thought were probably true.
He launched it out and said,
well,
I think these things are probably true.
It's like,
well,
probably their true well,
so he paid a price for it,
but maybe we'll see what sort of price
he paid for it.
Man,
it's going to be a lot tougher in two
years than he was two years ago.
So new.
No one.
They didn't answer his feedback.
No,
no,
but you can watch the video,
the stories there.
But that's kind of the outline of it.
So sorry to monopolize this.
I have one other question about this and
I think it's important,
aside from Google just being a
workplace,
right?
It also controls the own youtube,
Which is post a new censorship scheme
and it controls a huge amount of the
information that people get and so true
and so what happens to society when
companies such as Google,
which control our information start to
censor not just how about the selves and
maybe the information that's coming out
to the rest of the world.
How much is this already happening and
how much.
What happens?
If we refuse to find out,
that would be good.
You know,
like I reviewed this,
this guy's document,
I did that yesterday and everything he
said was validated by the scientific
literature.
So what has happened is that someone has
been fired publicly by major corporation
for stating well,
scientific truths right there.
Exactly the sorts of things that I say
in my classes for example,
and the reason that I say to them is
because I read the literature,
it's not because I'm personally happy
about the facts.
I think Iq research particularly is so
dismal that you can't possibly read it
without being seriously disheartened if
I could reconstruct the world.
So that ICU,
the ICU research wasn't true.
Well,
it sure be tempting,
you know,
but that's not how science works.
Science doesn't tell you what you,
what you want to hear,
it just tells you the way it bloody well
is.
And he got pilloried for.
He got pilloried for revealing a good
fraction of current scientific knowledge
about gender differences.
Okay.
That's not good.
And as you said,
that's a big company and it controls our
communication.
It's how about we do what we can to
ensure that these large communication
companies don't get to impose
a
factually false ideological structure on
the rest of the planet.
Or you can think about supporting this.
This guy who blew the whistle,
there's a fundraiser for him online.
He could use some money.
He wants to sue google.
Yeah,
maybe we could.
Maybe we could let them know that hiring
a human resources director who's also
concerned with equity is probably not a
good idea for capitalist company.
Why in the world would you hire your own
enemies?
I don't understand that so well,
we'll see how the dialogue continues,
but back to the personal like
you need to say what you think because
that's where you come from.
Right?
And if you don't say what you think,
then you kill your unborn self.
That's what you do.
That's what Cain did when he killed Abel
and that's why his punishment was
unbearable.
You know you have things in you that are
struggling to come to the light.
That's the truth.
You need data and you need to either
that truth because without that truth,
who cannot live in the world because the
world is real and you need truth to live
in the world,
and if you stifle your truth,
well,
how,
how can that be anything but something
that brings about hell,
how could it be any other way?
So you think,
well,
why should you speak up?
That's easy because the consequences of
not speaking up,
although delayed are far worse.
That's the reason.
If it can't be courage,
it could at least be prudent.
So.
Yep.
One more,
uh,
Dr Peterson.
First of all,
Kudos for mentioning Magnolias one of my
favorite movie.
It's a great movie,
man.
So
a few months ago I had a dream and when
I told someone this dream,
they suggested that I read the book of
revelations.
Oh yeah,
that's a bad dream that,
um,
the,
there's a lot of interesting stuff in
that book.
The thing that really,
that I found really interesting right
off the bat was the state is
represented,
uh,
in two instances as female,
positively and negatively.
And I was wondering if you had any
thoughts on that in the context of like
in maps of meaning,
you often talk about the state just as a
as male or as masculine.
Okay.
First of all,
I'm going to comment on your tee shirt.
That's a lobster hierarchy with horace
at the top,
isn't it?
It's even better.
Yeah,
it's the.
I have a lobster.
The best one that we found.
That's a good one.
Well,
now in really cracked me up when I saw
it.
I really thought that was funny,
man.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I'm on.
My graduate students used to meet,
when I first talked about this lobster
stuff,
we'd meet for breakfast and they were
very combative,
snappy group of graduate students and
they're always trying to one up each
other with jokes and whenever one really
pulled a good joke on another,
they'd stand up and it was really.
It was really funny.
Okay.
Let's see.
Can I answer that question?
You know how if you're looking at a.
If you look at a room,
every color that you see is dependent on
every other color in the room,
right?
Your eyes adjust to that.
So for example,
if you're in a room based with red
light,
your eyes will in some sense remove the
red so you can still see the colors.
Okay,
so your perception is to some degree on
call is to some degree dependent on con
context and that's one of the things
that makes the symbolic symbolic
interpretations tricky because to see
how something is represented
symbolically,
you actually have to look at the broader
narrative context within which the
symbols are embedded.
So for example,
let me see if I can get this right.
If the.
If the story has an island in an ocean,
then the ocean is often symbolically
feminine and the island is symbolically
masculine.
But if the stories,
the island and the sky,
then the island often become
symbolically masculine and feminine and
the Sky Symbolically Masculine and you
might think,
well,
how can the Ireland be masculine and
feminine at the same time?
And the answer is,
well,
it depends on what,
what is being contrasted with and why,
and so that's part of the key to the
change in symbolism in the book of
revelation.
And so it isn't inevitably the case that
culture is represented with the
patriarchal symbolism,
but it's most commonly the case.
So you know,
there is mother,
Russia for example.
I guess it would depend to some degree
too on what your metaphor is for the
state because the state can be an all
providing mother or it can be judgmental
father and it,
it seems that we tilt more towards the
father with regards to terminology
relating to the state.
And I think the reason for that is
because I think human hierarchies like
chimp hierarchies are fundamentally
masculine.
The fundamental hierarchies,
Even with chimps,
there's a female hierarchy,
but it's like the female hierarchy is
nested within the male hierarchy.
It's not the case with bonobos exactly.
But I think it is the case with human
beings.
And so I think we have a strong
proclivity to masculinize the state,
but that doesn't mean there aren't
exceptions.
That and symbol,
symbolic representations are very
slippery that way because you can't
stamp an entity with assemble because
that would be the same as just giving it
a name.
Right,
and you can't have a dictionary of
symbols where you say,
well,
you know,
a house always means the psyche.
It's like,
no.
Sometimes the house means the psyche,
but it depends on the story and so you
have to take the entire structure of the
narrative into account to determine why
those particular symbolic
representations are being used.
When I offered in maps of meaning was
kind of a shorthand,
you know,
generally speaking,
there's nature positive and negative.
Usually feminine.
Generally speaking,
there's culture positive and negative.
Usually masculine and generally
speaking,
there's the individual good and evil,
right?
Heroic can adversarial often typically
represented as masculine,
especially in adventure stories,
but it's a ski mountain and it's an
interpretive guide and not a set of hard
and fast rules because you're in the
domain of metaphor and it's a.
it's a slippery domain.
So do you have any luck figuring out
your dream?
Sorry,
did you have any luck figuring out your
dream?
At least in some parts.
I think there's different levels of
analysis.
I mean one was pretty obvious.
Yeah.
Alright.
Well thank you very much.